Bock.
Kategorie ist noch falsch.
Auf Twitch sehe ich gerade, ob es das jetzt gecheckt hat.
So, erstmal ausmachen.
Ich will mir nicht Werbung von meinem eigenen Zeug angucken.
Äh, hat es das? Ja, hat es gecheckt.
Excellent.
So, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen leiser machen.
Oder mal irgendwas anderes.
Irgendwas anderes.
Was ist das?
Das ist Mario Paint, Alter.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Das war ein Super Nintendo Game,
wo du Musik machen konntest
und Zeugs malen.
Mario Paint.
Da gab es eine Maus für den Super Nintendo.
Mario Paint, Alter.
Ich erinnere mich noch dran.
Ich glaube, das Game hatte keine Speichermöglichkeiten.
Das war richtig Fail.
Ja, ja, ich habe geswitcht.
Die Kategorie war verkehrt.
Die Kategorie war falsch.
Ja, Leute.
Gucken, was uns YouTube heute vorschlägt.
HsYui19 Monate.
Massive Subscriptions hier.
Exquisite.
Ist der Discord-Bot kaputt?
Ich gucke mal, ich guck mal kurz in Discord rein,
ob der Discord-Bot kam gerade.
Okay, jetzt gucken.
Stream Ankündigung.
Ja, er hat es gecheckt.
Nicht so, nicht so schnell.
Ja, ist das schon der neue GIF Player?
Moment, Moment, Moment, Achtung, Achtung.
Nein, das nicht der neue GIF Player.
Der neue GIF-Player ist ja auch nicht wirklich in irgendeinem Zustand, wo er funktioniert.
Das Einzige, was der macht, ist aktuell GIFs furchtbar schnell abspielen.
Twitch ist früher als Discord.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Discord-Bots sind in letzter Zeit ein bisschen langsam.
Entweder hat Amazon übelst aufgerüstet.
Oder Discord-Bots sind langsamer geworden.
Moin.
M-R-F-L-B-R.
Zwei Monate.
Massive Sub hier.
So, YouTube, letzte Chance.
Oh, guck mal, YouTube schlägt mir mein eigenes Video vor.
Excellent.
Erst mal die Klicks kurz generieren.
Also, YouTube, schlag mir mal was Gescheites vor.
Ich habe schon ein paar Sachen offen.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja noch mehr.
YouTube sagt, das soll ich unbedingt gucken.
Okay, excellent.
Ah, jetzt TypeScript.
Also, JavaScript-Magic ist mir heute einfach zu hoch.
Schneller kündigen und kürzere Laufzeit.
Ach so, es geht um Handys.
Ich dachte, ich könnte jetzt einfach...
So, Chef, morgen bin ich weg.
Will ich zwar nicht, aber wäre gut, wenn man das machen könnte.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich nachmittags weitermache.
Ich wollte mir eigentlich heute noch Dings angucken.
Windows 11.
Äh, Insider-Bild.
Das müssen wir uns eigentlich auch noch angucken.
Das sind immer so glückliche...
Was?
Was zum...
Was machen die da überhaupt?
Ach so, das soll Vater, Mutter im Bett sein und zwei Kinder am Start mit dem Convertible-Surface-Dings.
Meine Güte, ey.
Wie sie immer so oft...
Glückliche Familie machen und irgendwelche Notebooks dafür in die Mitte stellen.
Ich glaube, die Familie wäre am glücklichsten ohne so ein fucking Notebook dabei.
Jetzt wird Windows drauf.
Aber ausgerechnet so sehen Windows Insider aus.
Naja, gut.
Wir wissen ja spätestens, dass seit der Windows 11-Ankündigung wissen wir ja,
dass Leute im Krankenhaus, nachdem sie ein Kind zur Welt gebracht haben,
erstmal einen Teams-Call machen mit der Oma.
Ich weiß, du schaust es nicht, aber heute Abend ist...
GDQ21-Start.
Doch, ich gucke wahrscheinlich ein bisschen rein, aber ich gucke nicht mehr so viel,
seit sie den Chat auf Sub-Only haben.
Also seit sie den Chat auf Sub-Only haben und so mega korrekt sind mit allem.
Die haben ja beispielsweise schon Leute ausgeladen, weil sie irgendwie einen blöden Witz gemacht haben
über Fluggesellschaften und sowas.
Ich kann es auch über echt übertreiben.
Oder Trihacks haben sie letztens ausgeladen, weil er irgendwas irgendwie...
Was Dummes...
Mit seinen Freunden im Team-Speak gesagt hat und so.
Also ich finde, die übertreiben es.
Windows Insider, alle glückliche Großfamilien und sicher nicht 14...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Windows 11-User, gerade Windows Insider.
Das hier sind die wahren Windows Insider.
Wisst ihr, was mich immer noch beeindruckt?
Dass die ernsthaft...
Bist du krank?
Nee, das sagen alle über Anfang am Stream.
Ich muss immer erst mich warm reden.
Wie die ernsthaft...
Was ist denn das für eine komische Border?
Um das Ding, das sieht da mega hässlich aus.
Naja, gut.
Microsoft Web Design.
Dann war es nie so genau.
Was wollte ich denn sagen?
Ich finde es immer noch beeindruckend, dass die ernsthaft mit Windows in der Mitte werben.
Ich finde, diesen Windows-Knopf in der Mitte ist so extrem unergonomisch.
Also mir ist es egal.
Ich drücke eh die Windows-Taste.
Aber manchmal, manchmal drücke ich es auch von Hand.
Und links unten die Windows-Taste ist total easy.
Weil du haust einfach deine Maus unten links hin und klickst.
Das kannst du hier jetzt nicht machen.
Also wer ernsthaft auf die Idee gekommen ist,
dass der Button in der Mitte irgendwie ergonomischer ist,
der hat echt den Schuss dann mal gehört.
Naja, man kann es umstellen.
Aber das Problem ist, dass es Default ist.
Warum macht man Sachen, die unergonomischer sind, Default?
Man kann in Windows nahezu alles irgendwie an irgendeiner Art umstellen.
Sei es mit irgendwelchen Oldschool-Registry-Hacks oder sowas.
Aber ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht,
warum man etwas unergonomischeres als Default macht.
Ich verstehe, dass sie sagen,
hey, es ist präsenter in der Mitte vom Bildschirm, wenn man dieses Menü macht.
Es spricht ja nichts dagegen,
dass man das Menü in die Mitte machen würde.
Selbst wenn man links hinklickt.
Dann macht man das Menü halt so fett.
Dann ist es doch eigentlich egal.
Oder man macht die Gnome-3-Geschichte,
dass halt das Startmenü einfach so aufgeht.
Ja, warum ist es ein Startmenü?
Also, den Startknopf legen sie nicht für Tablets zu benutzen.
Das hat ja mit der Plattform nichts zu tun.
Außerdem sind die meisten User garantiert keine Tablet-User mit Windows.
Also, sprich, also nochmal, warum macht man etwas unergonomischeres,
was 80% der Benutzer betrifft, Default,
und macht nicht einfach einen If,
wenn man es wirklich für ergonomischer in der Mitte hält,
einfach einen If, sagt, ey, wenn es ein Tablet ist,
dann ist es halt in der Mitte, meinetwegen.
Also, ich kann die Microsoft-Logik da immer noch nicht ganz nachvollziehen.
Wobei ich es auch nicht wirklich jetzt extrem schlimm finde,
Hauptsache, Hauptsache der Kram funktioniert.
Und ich hoffe, die Windows-Suche funktioniert mal irgendwie,
weil, naja, File Search ist halt komplett broken, ne?
Keck W, was findet der Mensch nach Keck W Suche?
Dungeon Keeper Gold, excellent.
Äh, sakt, sakt.
Und warum ist, warum ist sogar die Windows,
Warum ist die Windows-Seite,
einfach, äh, kaputt?
Guck mal, die Windows-Seite ist einfach broken im Chrome.
Die meisten lassen es so, wie es ist.
Ja, das ist ja genau der Punkt, warum es unsinnig ist,
was uneconomischeres als Default zu machen.
Dann nervt es die meisten Leute, ohne dass sie wissen,
dass es sie richtig nervt.
Die sind einfach nur unzufrieden und wissen nicht genau, woran es liegt.
Es ist einfach bescheuert, so was, äh, Default zu machen.
Der, der einzige Grund ist, dass man
weniger Erneuerung als mehr Erneuerung verkaufen kann.
Das ist der einzige Grund,
warum die so einen Scheiß machen.
Oh, Leute, wenn ich die Musik höre.
Welcher Spruch muss jetzt im Chat kommen?
Ihr wisst es genau.
Gucken wir mal, ob es der Chat weiß.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher.
Der Chat weiß es nicht.
Fast richtig, fast richtig.
So.
Äh, das, das, das verstehe ich nicht.
Windows ist nur ein Spiele-Launcher.
Viele Leute verwenden Windows für alles Mögliche.
Es gibt sogar Leute, die programmieren Sachen,
unter Windows.
Ich kann es zwar auch nicht verstehen,
außer es ist Windows-only, aber das gibt es.
Aber soll jeder machen, wie er will.
Ja, also YouTube ist nicht in der Lage,
mir gerade gescheite Sachen, ähm, zu empfehlen.
Ich meine, ich habe hier schon genug Sachen offen.
Ja, Windows Server ist eh das Schlimmste.
Und wisst ihr, was ich geil finde?
Dass Leute, die, äh, also zum, äh, gut.
Ich, ich kann jetzt natürlich nicht, äh, allgemein sprechen für alle.
Aber wisst ihr, was meine Erfahrung mit Windows-Admins ist?
Dass die auch keine Ahnung haben,
was sie eigentlich machen.
Gerade bei uns ist es immer so,
wenn, wenn es irgendwelche Berechtigungsfehler gibt,
weil du auf irgendwas nicht zugreifen kannst,
dann liegt das in der Regel immer daran,
dass einem irgendwelche Active Directory-Berechtigungen fehlen.
So, dann gehst du zu den Leuten bei uns,
die Active Directory machen.
Und dann sagst du, ja, ich kann, keine Ahnung,
denken wir uns jetzt mal was aus,
ich kann aufs Ticketsystem nicht zugreifen.
Äh, ich glaube, das liegt an Active Directory-Berechtigungen.
Könnt ihr mir das einrichten?
Und dann fragen die dich ernsthaft, ja,
welche Gruppe soll ich hinzufügen?
Dann sag ich, keine Ahnung,
die Gruppe, die dafür zuständig ist,
dass man eben, äh, Ticketsystem-Berechtigungen hat.
Ja, wie heißt denn die Gruppe?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist so ein Henne-Ei-Problem, wisst ihr?
Du kannst auf was nicht zugreifen, sollst aber wissen,
wie die Active Directory-Gruppe heißt,
für das nur, wo du keine Rechte drauf hast.
So, was bei dir für eine Web-Application läuft,
das muss ich hier Overlays anzeigen.
Und, was, der Breathing-PC ist geil.
Okay, jetzt können wir uns gleich,
gleich dann mal ankommen, wenn das, wenn das nice ist.
Oh, ne, 18 Minuten, dann muss ich wieder,
muss ich wieder vorskippen.
So.
Und, das wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau,
und das, das wird ja dann,
das wird dann immer noch besser mit der Zeit.
Dann, dann nervst du weiter rum, sagst du,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht,
welche Berechtigungen fürs Ticketsystem zuständig sind.
So, und dann sagen sie,
welcher User hat denn, hat denn noch,
hat denn auch noch Berechtigungen?
Und wir haben uns letztens mal den Spaß gemacht,
ja, Felix und ich, wir hatten, also ich durfte
auf das Tickets, oder ich sag jetzt einfach mal Ticketsystem,
ich durfte auf das Ticketsystem zugreifen
und der Felix durfte nicht auf das Ticketsystem zugreifen.
Da haben wir uns letztens mal den Spaß gemacht
und haben mit irgendeinem, ich weiß nicht mal, was es war,
mit irgendeinem PowerShell-Kommando ausgelesen,
in welchen AD-Gruppen er ist und in welchen AD-Gruppen ich bin.
Und wir sind zu dem Schluss gekommen,
wir sind beide in über, passt mal auf, haltet euch fest,
in über 300 Gruppen, in über 300 Gruppen.
Und irgendwie in 80 unterschiedlichen Gruppen.
Eine von diesen 80 unterschiedlichen Gruppen
ist das Tickets, ist die Ticketsystem-Berechtigung.
Ja. So, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Und jetzt kommt, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Daraufhin hatten sie keine Ahnung, welche, welche das ist.
Und was haben sie gemacht?
Sie haben den User von Felix neu erstellt
und haben ihn geklont aus meinem User mit den Berechtigungen.
Jetzt fehlen ihm wahrscheinlich Berechtigungen für alles andere.
Das ist so f...
Keine Ahnung, meine Erfahrung ist,
Windows-Admins haben auch absolut keinen Plan von dem, was sie machen.
Gebe es Twitch, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Active Direct ist Pains-Champ, ja, ist es.
Generell diese Microsoft-Server-Welt, alles, was nicht,
wobei selbst Microsoft hier Client-Welt-Windows,
Windows-Technik ist Pains-Champ.
Die Musik ein bisschen lauter.
Was ist denn der Everybody Votes Channel?
Hat jemand dokumentiert bei euch?
Ich glaube doch selbst nicht, dass das irgendwo steht.
Die, die ganzen AD-Gruppen haben irgendeinen Comment dran,
aber das ist, äh, ich hab das, ich hab das doch sogar mal,
ich hab das doch sogar mal, äh, auf Twitter gepostet,
so einen kleinen Auszug von, ein bisschen anonymisiert.
Unsere Gruppennamen sind so unglaublich wir,
die heißen dann so was wie, keine Ahnung, äh,
Test, DP, Underscore,
Old, Underscore, Notes, Underscore, IT,
Underscore, Admin, äh, keine Ahnung.
Das sind dann solche, das sind dann solche langen Gruppen oder so,
da blickt echt keiner mehr durch.
Hier.
So, äh, es gibt YouTube keine Videos,
die irgendwie wir uns noch zusätzlich angucken sollen, okay.
Excellent.
AD-Stream, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Also das werde ich mir nicht geben, Leute.
Also wir machen garantiert keinen Active Directory Stream.
Also bevor, bevor ich jemals in die Windows-Server-Welt gehe,
gehe, dann wechsle ich den Job.
Das mach ich nicht.
Ja, schieß los.
Aber nur, wenn der Chat mitmachen darf.
Ja, mach mal.
Genau, ungefähr so sehen unsere Benutzergruppen aus.
Da stellt so ein 16-Monatiger am Start Dankeschön für den Hyper-Subscription ab.
Das ist dynamisch gewachsen.
Ja, das ist bei uns auch immer die Aussage.
Wobei wir sagen nicht dynamisch gewachsen, sondern wir sagen meistens, das ist historisch gewachsen.
Äh, das ist irgendein Base64.
Guck mal.
Decoder.
Gucken wir mal.
Ist alles Toss-Safe?
Na, ich glaub dir mal.
Decode.
What the fuck?
Das sieht nicht Toss-Safe aus.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein komisches ist.
Das sieht immer noch ein bisschen verschlüsselt aus.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Da braucht man wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Tor-Browser, um das aufzumachen oder so.
Ey, Max, weißt du, ob die MikroTik-Switch- äh, ja?
Also, ob es die reinen Switche mit SwitchOS können, glaube ich nicht.
Aber die RouterOS sollten es eigentlich können.
Aber wirklich benutzt habe ich das noch nicht bei MikroTik.
Aber das können, also die RouterOS-Dinger können das.
Ist das Rot 13 oder so?
Komm, wir probieren das jetzt nochmal aus.
Okay.
Also.
Sagen wir mal, ob wir dahinter kommen.
So, dann brauchen wir das.
Äh, Rot-Decoder.
Gibt's ja alles als irgendwie.
Hier hat der Thomas Kühn, der nicht verschlüsselt.
Ich will's entschlüsselt haben, Alter.
Das check ich nicht.
Ah, hier.
HTTPS.
Okay, das mach, die Seite mach ich nicht auf.
Die Seite mach ich auf, auf dem zweiten, auf der zweiten Webseite auf.
Okay.
Naja.
Gut.
Wir haben's rausgekriegt.
Exzellent.
Oder ist, oder ist auf der Webseite noch irgendwas, was man finden kann im, im, im Source-Code?
Das war jetzt der erste Schritt.
Okay.
Ja, das machen wir jetzt aber nicht im Stream.
Aber ist ja eine interessante Idee.
Da müssen wir uns den Webseiten-Source-Code jetzt irgendwie nochmal angucken.
Okay, fangen wir mal an.
Was gucken wir uns an?
YouTube letzte Chance?
Okay, Battlefield 4.
34 Sekunden.
Das ist bestimmt Tostmusik.
Da kommen jetzt 50 Leute.
Da kommen jetzt 50 Leute raus oder so.
Hohohohoho.
Ja, okay.
Und weiter?
Noobs.
Alles, alles Noobs.
Weiß doch jeder.
Man hätte die Defi killen müssen.
Nicht, nicht einfach draufschießen.
Den Disrespect-Defi-Kill machen.
Ich hätte die alle entweder Defi killed oder Repair-Tool killed.
Easy.
Gar kein Problem.
Und YouTube kann uns nichts geschadet, empfehlen uns nichts Gescheites.
Also, da würde ich sagen, dann lassen wir uns mal wieder mal von LevelCaptchee baden.
Wir lassen uns mal eine Runde von LevelCaptchee baden.
Jedes Mal.
Und da kann ich jedes Mal sagen, Alter, was der wieder da draus macht, weiß doch eh schon jeder.
Noch nicht das neue Alpha 4 Games Video geschaut.
Doch, das habe ich gestern geschaut, aber das fand ich jetzt nicht so spannend, weil gerade das Spielgenre ist, was mich eh null juckt.
Hey Guys, LevelCapt hier.
This week in Gaming, we might get new Battlefield 2042 Info before EA Play Live.
Cheat.
Ich finde das immer so geil, ne?
Der, der, der Titel ist so am Anfang New Battlefield Gameplay Details und jetzt sagt er so, we might get new Battlefield Gameplay Details.
Das ist immer der gleiche Kram.
Übrigens, übrigens, ja, ja, es gibt, also ich kann nicht, also ich habe mich mal wieder verpflichtet.
Nichts zu sagen.
Ja, ja, es gibt neue Details.
Das ist korrekt.
... in Warzone has gone to a whole new level.
Kojima's next game might be an Xbox exclusive and much more.
Ja gut, wenn sie ihm genug Geld bezahlen, warum nicht, ne?
We may get some new Battlefield 2042 Info before EA Play Live kicks off on the 22nd.
Pause, Cem.
... three spotlight panels before the big event.
The first episode goes live on...
Ich finde das eh total langweilig.
Aktuell mit 2042.
Ja, es arbeiten sich alle an den gleichen Details ab und keiner hat sie jemals in Action gesehen.
Ich habe mir auch überlegt, ob ich noch ein zweites Video drüber machen sollte.
Zum Beispiel, was ich gerade sehr, sehr merkwürdig finde, ist, dass sich so viele Leute über die neuen Operator, die nicht Operator, sondern Specialists heißen, also diese Custom Klassen, dass sich gerade so viele Leute darüber aufregen, was Battlefield 2042 ausgeht.
Verstehe ich nicht, weil eigentlich ändert sich überhaupt nichts.
Also der Unterschied ist nur, dass früher die Klassen frei customizable waren.
Jetzt pickst du einen Operator und customizest den.
Also, wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Du konntest früher, hast du den Medic ausgewählt und hast dann customizest, ob du einen Defi mitnimmst oder ob du einen Smoke, ne, doch, ob du Smoke mitnimmst, ob du eine Shotgun mitnimmst oder was auch immer.
Also du hast deine Base-Klasse ausgewählt und die hast du customizest.
So, jetzt, jetzt wählst du den Operator aus und customizest den.
Das macht doch überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Also sprich, ob ich jetzt einen Medic auswähle, Medipack-Defi nehme, ob ich jetzt einen Assault-Sturmsoldat auswähle, Medipack-Defi nehme, ob ich jetzt einen Sturmsoldat auswähle, Smoke-Granate und Medipack nehme, macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
In Battlefield 2042 wäre es dann halt so.
Um das gleiche Beispiel zu nehmen, ich nehme den Operator mit dem Defi und rüste den mit nem Medipack aus.
Oder ich nehme den Operator mit dem Smoke-Granatenwerfer und geb dem nen, nen, nen, nen Heal, nen, nen, nen Medipack.
Also, rein von der Mechanik her ist das genau das gleiche wie customizables Base-Klassen.
Aber irgendwie weiß ich nicht, warum man sich da so drüber aufregt.
Der einzige Unterschied ist, es ist viel geiler zu monateln.
Also, wenn du nur 4 Klassen hast, ist das natürlich kacke.
Die kannst du zwar auch Skins anbieten und sonstwas, aber wenn du 10 Operator hast, kannst du Skins mal 10 anbieten.
Ist natürlich viel nicer.
Also, du kannst das besser monetarisieren. Für die ist das gut.
Gameplay-Technisch macht das, glaube ich, überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob es customisable Base-Klassen sind oder ob es customisable Operator sind mit einem festen Gadget.
Das macht in der Ausrüstung her überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Das, was viel größeren Unterschied macht beim neuen Battlefield ist, dass du jetzt jede Waffe mit jeder Klasse ausrüsten kannst.
Das hat aber mit den Operators nichts zu tun.
Da bin ich ja persönlich auch noch skeptisch, weil das wird dafür sorgen, dass es wieder so ein ähnliches Meta gibt wie in Warzone.
Dass 2-3 Waffen geil sind und der Rest spielt keiner mehr.
In den anderen Battlefield-Teilen war es immerhin so, dass es quasi so eine Best oder so 3 richtig gute Waffen,
wenn es Assault gibt, 3 richtig gute Waffen-Sniper, 3 richtig gute Waffen-Engineer und sowas.
Das wird jetzt nicht mehr so sein.
Wenn jeder alles ausrüsten kann und, sagen wir mal, ein Engineer-Operator auch keinen Bonus bekommt auf Sub-Machine-Guns oder so,
dann werden alle mit dem gleichen OP-Assault-Rifle rumrennen und alle mit der gleichen OP-Sniper rumrennen.
Das ist das, was ich jetzt eher doof finde.
Das ist nicht das Problem von den Operators, sondern die generelle Entscheidung.
Zumal man jetzt sogar noch einen Ticken weiter geht und sagt, man kann die Waffen customizen, während man im Spiel ist.
Also ich kann das Scope zu einem Red Dot tauschen mit meiner Semi-Auto-Sniper, je nachdem, wo ich unterwegs bin.
Das ist natürlich schon ein anderer Punkt, weil sowieso im Haus mit einem fetten Scope, ja.
Auf der Konsole kein Problem, gerade auf der Xbox 360 damals mit Auto-Aim.
Nee, aber keine Ahnung.
Das ist eher das Problem, finde ich.
Wann kommen die neuen Videos? Wir haben noch nichts aufgenommen.
Wir nehmen wahrscheinlich auch wieder erst was aus, was wirklich substanzielle Neuigkeiten gibt.
... und highlight the future of FPS with Battlefield 2042 and Apex Legends.
Developers from both games will talk about...
Alter, das macht mich immer fertig. Das Handy vibriere bei Level Cap.
... their work and likely drop hints about content to be announced during EA Play Live.
The second presentation goes live on the 13th and focuses on EAs Indie-Titles,
like It's X2.
The third will look at Madden 22.
A final fourth panel will go live on the 20th, but EA are keeping quiet about its content.
That said, Battlefield 2042's storage solution partner, Western Digital, is teasing an announcement on that date.
Was zum Teufel hat ein Festplattenhersteller mit Battlefield zu tun?
Das hätte ja besser zu Modern Warfare gepasst.
WD Black, Bravo Six... nee, wie hießen die?
Alpha Six? Nee, Bravo Six hießen die, oder? Ach, ich hab schon wieder vergessen.
Die Modern Warfare-Typen.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wann die Beta startet. Ich weiß nicht, wann die Beta startet.
Ich warte die ganze Zeit auch schon drauf auf...
Weil, die haben zu uns gesagt, es gibt ein Playtesting, eventuell sogar einen Internal Playtesting-Test, wo man daran teilnehmen kann.
Das sollte angeblich jetzt irgendwann kommen, aber ich hab davon auch nix gehört von EA.
Also, ist natürlich doof, ich würd's gern mal spielen.
Ja, und außerdem ist Warzone mittlerweile 500G oder so groß. Da hätten sie nen Festplattenpartner brauchen können.
...ein ton of time during EA Play's main event.
And because they're being broken out into their own presentations, this year's main event on the 22nd...
Ich hoffe, man darf restreamen. Ja, das reicht ja auch.
40 Minuten Inhalt ist auf jeden Fall besser als 40 Minuten Zeit.
40 Minuten sinnloses Kreisgelaber. Guckt euch mal die...
...Guckt euch mal die eineinhalb Stunden an...
...Guckt euch mal die eineinhalb Stunden Windows-Präsentation an.
Das war einfach nur eineinhalb Stunden sinnlos Gelaber.
Mir ist lieber, die zeigen 40 Minuten was und gut ist...
Wann kommt eigentlich FaceReveal? Ja, bei einer Million Abos.
Ja, und?
Ist das die Frau von der... Ja, das ist doch... Ist das Trinity aus der Matrix?
Die Bildauflösung ist so schlecht. Ja? Man erkennt das kaum.
...internal development tools, not anything players will ever interact with.
EA also announced Nvidia, Xbox and Logitech as official partners for the game.
The partnership with Nvidia adds DLSS and Reflex-Low-Latency-Options for 2042...
Ja, mach dir mal.
...which will be a significant performance boost for anyone with compatible hardware.
And before we get to the rest of Battlefield 2042 news, here's a quick word from today's sponsor.
Today's video is sponsored by my long-time PC hardware partner, Origin PC.
Origin... Das hat... Das hat jetzt nichts mit EA zu tun, wahrscheinlich.
Customizable, pre-built PCs with all sorts of... Origin PC.
Erst mal... Erst mal skippen.
Alright. Now, regarding EA Play Live, we know Battlefield 2042 and Apex Legends will be heavily featured.
DICE will cover 2042's hazard zone and...
Der hat's jetzt geschafft, hier wirklich dreieinhalb Minuten News drüber zu machen, ohne irgendwas zu sagen.
Das ist wirklich absolut next level. Da kann ich mir was von abgucken.
...during the presentation. The gameplay trailer DICE released last month was great, but it only gave us...
...und uns sehr laut gemacht zwischendurch.
Regarding potential announcements, a Dead Space remake or a new title may be revealed during EA Play Live.
Unfortunately, there won't be any Mass Effect or Dragon Age coverage.
BioWare confirmed that via Twitter. Overall, you can expect...
Genau, schön 10 Minuten 11 Sekunden lang.
Was? Okay, was schreibe ich? Bio... Ach, BioWare. BioWare.
Leute, ich muss euch ehrlich mal sagen, wenn ich sowas lese... Also, ich hab ja ein bisschen meine... mein Vertrauen in BioWare verloren.
Man sieht das einfach. Was war das letzte richtig gute BioWare Game? Dragon Age?
Wobei ich sagen muss, selbst schon das Original Dragon Age hat mir nicht mehr so gut gefallen wie die davor.
Aber das Original Dragon Age war schon noch ziemlich pock. Wobei ich sagen muss, dass gerade das Kampfsystem im Original Dragon Age war...
...irgendwie schwammig. Das war so eine Mischung aus wir wollen es Konsolen gerecht machen, wir wollen es aber doch PC gerecht machen...
...und wir wollen es aber doch PC gerecht machen.
machen, aber NPCs, äh, äh, Charakter verhalten sich manchmal nicht, was ich gesagt habe
und manchmal machen sie selbst, also, ganz merkwürdig, also, das Original Dragon Age
war schon cool, aber ich muss schon sagen, so, ich find, also, das Original Dragon Age
und, sagen wir mal so, Mass Effect, wenn man die Games mag, ja, die waren sicherlich auch
nicht verkehrt, aber spätestens ab Dragon Age 2 war vorbei.
Ja, da hab ich gestern, da hab ich gestern das Video, das können wir uns übrigens auch
nochmal angucken, da hab ich gestern das Video zugesehen, das sind irgendwelche Leute, die
haben sich ne, äh, Endgame, Battlefield 3 Endgame DLC Map rausgesucht, haben die ein
bisschen umgebaut und wollen da jetzt ein Battle Royale drauf entwickeln.
Ich bin, ihr kennt mich, ja, ähm, ich bin Sam.
Skeptisch, was das Ganze angeht, weil das ist wieder so ein, so ein, so ein typischer
Mod, die Basics sind immer easy zu programmieren.
Also, die Basics von nem Battle Royale, die würde wahrscheinlich, also, ich hab absolut
keine Ahnung von Spieleentwicklung, aber würde, würde mir jemand ne Engine mit ordentlichen
Tools und schon einer fertigen Map in die Hand drücken, die Basics von so nem Battle
Royale, nen Flugzeug fliegt rüber, spawnt Leute und du setzt random nen Circle, der
immer sich halbiert und, und, und kleiner random über die Map wandelt.
Also, die Basics, die könnte ich wahrscheinlich auch in zwei, drei Tagen programmieren, obwohl
ich keine Ahnung von Spieleprogrammierung hab.
Das Komplexe liegt sicherlich im Detail.
Deswegen bin ich immer skeptisch bei so Community-Mods.
Die sehen am Anfang immer super promising aus, weil du halt schnelle, große Schritte
machen kannst und es sieht halt cool aus und es passiert sich viel, aber die verlaufen
sich dann oftmals nach, äh, paar Monaten Entwicklung, weil sie feststellen, fuck, im
Detail ist es ja doch nicht so einfach.
Ja, zum Beispiel möchten die.
Battlefield, das hab ich gesehen, das, wir gucken uns mal, wartet mal, wir gucken, wir
gucken uns mal kurz das Video an, dann kann ich mal meinen Senf zugeben, weil ich finde,
es hätte sogar ein gewisses Potenzial, wenn tatsächlich Battlefield 2042 kein Battle
Royale haben sollte.
Äh, ja.
Ne, ne, das ist nicht Battlefield 3.
Ja, super, da zeigt, da zeigt das, da zeigt den Blog, da zeigt den Blogpost.
Blogpost kann ich euch auch zeigen.
Dev-Blog.
Ich verfolge ja diese Venice-Unleashed-Geschichte immer noch ein bisschen, hier.
Battle-Royale-Mob.
Also, ähm, alles, also ich will das jetzt auch nicht schlecht reden, ja, wirklich nicht.
Ähm, aber was man halt bisher gesehen hat, ist ein Flugzeug, was spawnt, so eine Circle-Mechanik
und ne bisschen, bisschen customizable Map.
Das ist was, ich weiß nicht, wie gut die, die Modding-Tools für Venice sind aktuell,
kann ich, kann ich nicht einschätzen, aber wenn, wenn man schon ne mehr oder weniger
fertige Map hat, sag mal so, so ne, so ne Flugzeug-Sache zu, zu scripten und nen Circle zu bauen,
das ist nicht schwer.
Ja, sie haben so ein Ping-System eingebaut, was halt äußerst rudimentär und basic aussieht,
aber sie wollen zum Beispiel auch, äh, Inventar-Management und sowas einbauen
und da fängt's an, kompliziert zu werden.
Da musst du viel darauf achten, wie so die Interaction ist, dass du nicht aus Versehen
Waffen vervielfältigen kannst und sowas, da musst du halt auch gucken, dass du das ordentlich
bugfrei programmierst.
Das ist im Detail dann schon wieder gar nicht mehr so einfach, deswegen hab ich immer das
Gefühl, dass solche Community-Mods sich oftmals totlaufen, ja.
Die ersten zwei, drei Monate ultra gehypt, alle sind dabei, viel Progress gemacht, aber
das, das, das richtig Komplizierte, das wird dann nie fertig.
Fantastic.
The Mod will feature a heavily modified and expanded Map, a Circle of Death similar to
Firestorms, a custom Dropship, Ping-System and an in-depth Loot-System that lets you
customize individual attachments.
There's no ETA for the Mod's launch, but playtesting should start in the next couple
of months.
Ja, ja, der Mod, der kommt wahrscheinlich vor zwei Jahren oder so nicht raus.
Die haben ja auch gesagt, diesen Battle, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diesen Battlefield 3 Reality
Mod ein bisschen verfolgt.
Finde ich von der Idee her auch gar nicht schlecht.
Reality Mod.
Das sollte angeblich im ersten Quartal 2021 spielbar sein für alle.
Die sind, glaube ich, bis heute nicht mal ansatzweise so weit.
Also.
Das ist ja auch total unfähig.
Ja, Raph und Soft ist ja auch total unfähig.
Ja.
Sie können Spieler in der Lobby aus dem Spiel auslösen, weil sie einen Fehler verursachen.
All das passiert, obwohl Raven jahrelang Tausende Spieler banniert hat.
Leute, habe ich nicht genau das letzte Woche gesagt?
Wenn die alle paar Tausend Spieler bannen, ist das einfach nichts.
Das ist einfach ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein.
Die machen sich neu in den Account und gut ist.
Und selbst wenn.
Das ist ja eh nur ein Bruchteil von denen, die es betrifft.
Oder DHL-Simulator, ne?
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe es nicht einmal angeworfen bisher.
Gibt es ja mittlerweile auf Steam.
Hast du schon mal was mit Unreal oder Unity gemacht?
Wie gesagt, ich habe absolut nichts.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was die Spieleentwicklung angeht.
Dementsprechend habe ich noch nichts gemacht mit weder Unreal noch Unity.
Wenn ich was machen würde, dann auf jeden Fall mit Unity, weil ich dann in C-Sharp programmieren kann und nicht in C++.
Ich weiß, man kann in Unreal auch viel Blueprint-Geklicke machen, wobei ich ehrlich bin, das weiß ich nicht, ob mir das so zusagt.
Aber ich kann es auch nicht richtig einschätzen, weil ich da nichts mitgemacht habe.
Aber ich würde wahrscheinlich Unity nehmen.
Und wenn ich irgendwas 2D-mäßiges machen würde.
Vielleicht auch.
Irgendwas ganz anderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber ich habe von Spieleentwicklung keinen Plan.
Warum nicht Crytek?
Cry Engine 9 auf gar keinen Fall.
Was ist?
Ich glaube, Cry Engine ist auch C++, aber weil ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin.
Aber soll dokumentationstechnisch und tutorial- und materialmäßig absolut schlecht und eklig sein.
Hat schon einen Grund, warum Star Citizen nicht rauskommt.
Das hat einen Grund, warum es Cry Engine heißt, ja.
Was macht es? Was macht es?
Star Citizen eigentlich so, wenn ich das gerade sehe.
Das ist ja nicht Star Citizen, das ist Elite Dangerous.
Aber was macht Star Citizen aktuell eigentlich so?
In somewhat shocking news, Games Retailer Humble Bundle will stopp allow...
Mobile Games.
Ne, wir sehen keine Mobile Games.
... great prices on amazing games, books and software, all while supporting important charitable initiatives with every single purchase.
Die Medien- und Unternehmensfirma IGN hat Humble im Jahr 2017 erhoben.
Die Dinge wurden wie immer unter neuer Führung durchgeführt, bis Humble die Erkennung der
Charitablen-Donationen-Limite vor dem letzten Jahr erhielt.
Sie haben schnell die Entscheidung gewechselt, die Charitablen-Donationen zu 15% von jeder
Verleihung ein paar Monate her.
Diese neue Veränderung wird ein Minimum von 15% benötigen, um direkt zu Humble für
jede Verleihung zu gehen.
Die Reaktion zu dieser Veränderung auf sozialen Medien war sehr negativ.
Viele sehen es als einen günstigen Versuch, den Profit zu erhöhen.
Natürlich, was soll's, ja was meint ihr denn, warum die den Laden gekauft haben?
Sicherlich nicht, um krass, äh, wohltätig zu sein.
... Business Model for the company.
Going forward, they'll still offer select bundles that donate all proceeds to charity,
but users won't be able to do the same thing for all purchases.
HID Software announced that the development of Doom Eternals PvP Invasion Mode has been scrapped.
The mode would let players enter the campaign of another player as a demon.
Hä?
Du wolltest grad sagen, das war wie bei Dark Souls.
... but the pandemic forced HID to prioritize other content like the game's two DLC expansions.
Instead of releasing the Invasion Mode, HID are working on a new single player...
Was genau hatte Corona damit zu tun jetzt?
Ich hab mittlerweile das Gefühl, Corona ist die Standardantwort für alles.
So nach dem Motto, ja warum macht ihr jetzt auf einmal B, obwohl ihr gesagt habt, ihr macht A, äh, Corona.
They didn't outline what this mode will offer, but they say it'll add more of the diversity...
Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn.
Ich bin heute Morgen übrigens nach dem Aufstehen nicht aufs Klo gegangen. Warum? Äh, Corona.
Moment, ist das Pupke?
Moment, ist das Pupke oder ist das H1Z1?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist Pupke.
Oh, Pupke.
Es wird live auf den 7. für PC-Player und auf den 15. für Konsole-Player ausgelöst.
Wenn ihr Probleme habt, decent FPS in Microsoft Flight Sim zu bekommen,
könnte die nächste Update etwas Salvation erzielen.
Die Entwickler haben einen riesigen Schaden...
...in Gebiete der Welt, aber Flugsimulator hatte ich gedacht, nö, brauchen wir nicht.
Die haben, die haben ein generiertes Frankfurter Main Stadtgebiet aus Google-Karten, äh, nee, aus Microsoft-Karten und, oder aus Bing, Bing Maps heißt es ja, glaube ich.
Aber das sieht halt, wenn du drüber fliegst, nur sehr am Rande nach Frankfurter Main aus.
Also, du hast ein paar Gebäude, die erkennst du wieder, aber beispielsweise da, wo der, äh, Main Tower steht,
ein großes, steht ein großer, schwarzer, ähm, Sky School, äh, was heißt das auf Deutsch, äh, Hochhaus, ähm, Wolkenkratzer und kein Main Tower und sowas, es ist fail, ja.
...chunks of the game's engine and radically optimized its CPU usage.
With the update applied, you should see about a 25% reduction in CPU utilization by the game.
That'll give your PC more headroom to run the game while also boosting FPS by as much as...
...30 in some situations.
All of the testing the developer presented was done at sub-1080p resolution, so chances are...
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt den Frankfurter Flughafen als Download, das weiß ich, aber ich rede ja von der, von der Stadt.
Da weiß ich nicht, ob es das als Download gibt.
Zumindest im Original-Base-Game sieht Frankfurter Stadtgebiet halt nur äußerst entfernt nach Frankfurt aus.
Was stimmt, ist der Main und die Brücke drüber, das können sie ja gut aus Bing Maps sich rausziehen, aber die ganze Gebäudeplatzierung,
und auch die Interpretation der Hochhäuser, äh, das, äh, Flugsimulator-Algorithmus, was das eben aus Bing Maps macht,
hat mit der Realität nicht allzu viel zu tun.
...our real world results will be a bit less dramatic, but either way it is good news.
The update launches on the 27th.
If you ever wanted to play Game Boy Titles on your PC...
Warum nur den Frankfurter? Weil mich der Leipziger Flughafen nicht interessiert.
In, in Leipzig haben die beim DHL-Paket, glaub, drei Wochen, äh, nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
...auf die Reihe bekommen. In Leipzig haben die beim DHL-Paket, glaub, drei Wochen, äh, nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
In Leipzig haben die beim DHL-Paket, glaub, drei Wochen, äh, nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
Die kriegen keinen Flugsimulator-Update. Frankfurt ist mir wichtiger.
...reporting to illegally downloading ROMs for games you don't own, retro gaming company Epilog might have the perfect product.
Ja, ja, ja, Level, Levelcap G-Bait.
...they just announced the GB Operator.
Ist das ein Toaster?
...it's a $50 Cartridge Dock that accepts Game Boy Titles from the original handheld Device all the way up to the Game Boy Advanced.
It comes with an emulator program that will load and play any game connected via the Dock.
Also, also wenn ich das eh, also wenn ich quasi...
...einen Cartridge-Schlott habe und original Games brauche, die ich dann emuliert spiele...
...das ist ja wahrscheinlich eh schon so eine Grauzone...
...da kann ich mir wahrscheinlich auch gleich irgendwo den ROM runterladen, wenn ich das Original spiele, ist dann genauso Grauzone.
You can also use other emulators if you want. It can also back up your cartridge's save file in case the battery has died.
Emulation using ROMs is the most popular way of playing Game Boy Titles on the PC these days, Ja.
...but for...
...$50, this Dock seems like a pretty great investment for folks with lots of game cartridges in their collection.
Bald wieder IT-Mythen. Ja, da brauch ich ein paar Themen für.
Before we get to our final story of the week, thanks for tuning in. We'll be back with more gaming news coverage on Monday.
Let us know what you thought the most interesting...
By the way, eh, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das ist ja das Gameplay, was wir schon gesehen haben, ich hoffe, dass es im Original ein bisschen, warte mal, lass mal hier hin, dass es im Original alles ein bisschen klarer und weniger blurry ist.
Guckt euch das mal an. Du erkennst ja absolut gar nichts.
Hätten die hier nicht grüne Namen überschritten...
...über den Leuten, du würdest den nicht, du würdest, würdest du, würdet ihr den erkennen?
Ich würd nix erkennen.
Also ich hoffe, dass es dann weniger, dass es jetzt halt cinematic ist, aber weniger blurry und weniger, weniger, eh...
...wir alles, ja.
...back with more gaming news coverage on Monday.
Let us know what you thought the most interesting story was in the comments and have a great weekend.
Grand Theft Auto 6 Rumors from Battlefield-Leaker Tom Henderson made the rounds this week.
Tom claims that the game will be set in modern...
...day Vice City and...
Das ist ne Grauzone.
ROMs sind allgemeine Grauzone.
Also überhaupt sind solche Dinger immer schwierig, ja? Also...
...launches latest 2025.
He says the game's map will grow and change over time, like Fortnite with seasonal events.
It'll also offer a variety of playable characters.
Any GTA 6 info should be treated...
Ja, GTA als Resident-Sweeper.
...hasn't said a word about the game yet.
But Tom's claims sort of line up with...
...reality.
Rockstar's parent company, Take-Two Interactive, will be spending 90 million dollars on marketing...
Der Cartridge-Slot spielt ja nicht die Spiele.
Der Cartridge-Slot ist quasi ein Lesegerät.
Was die Spiele spielt, ist ein ganz normaler Emulator.
Und ob inwieweit da nicht irgendwelche Rechte verletzt werden oder sonst was...
Ich glaube, das kannst weder du noch ich als klar Ja oder Nein beantworten.
Deswegen sag ich ja Grauzone.
...which is a lot more than usual.
That's a pretty good indication that GTA 6 will at least be revealed that year.
They spent 128 million dollars marketing GTA 5, according to Wikipedia.
Ja, GTA 5 ist, äh, eines der größten, äh, quasi Money-Macht-Dinger aller Zeiten, ne?
Catch you next time, this is LevelCap, signing off.
Stimmt, was macht eigentlich Elder Scrolls 6?
Hat man davon irgendwas gehört in letzter Zeit?
Nee, oder?
Glaub nicht.
Gab's dazu irgendwas bei der E3?
Vielleicht?
Elder Scrolls 6.
Vor 20 Stunden hat er was.
Okay, Ted Howard, wenn der gut...
20 times the detail, oder wieviel waren's?
16 times the detail, oder...
Ach, was auch immer.
Also, was Todd erzählt, sollte ja nun mittlerweile niemand mehr glauben.
Ich mein, die haben's ganz schön verkackt, ne?
Skyrim kam wann? 2013 oder so?
Nee, 2011! 2011, Alter, kam das schon!
Das ist 10 Jahre alt, die haben's...
Guck mal, Skyrim war übelst erfolgreich.
Und die haben's innerhalb von 10 Jahren, sieht man mal was bei denen ab, dass bei denen überhaupt
keiner mehr irgendwie fähige Leute hat, ähm, die haben es bei so nem mega erfolgreichen
Game nicht, nicht geschafft, in 10 Jahren irgendwas Vorzeigbares zu machen.
Sie haben ein komisches, äh, mobile, mobile, äh, Elder Scrolls gemacht, was sagt?
Nee, also...
Die sind, glaub ich, nicht mehr in der Lage...
noch was zu machen.
Okay, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Das ist bestimmt Resident Sleeper.
Okay, wir lassen uns mal nicht spo...
Was ist denn das? Okay, Moment, das müssen wir uns jetzt anschauen.
Aber, aber, ich, ich skippe, ich skippe die langweiligen Parts, sag ich euch gleich.
Elder Scrolls 6 wird mittlerweile für 2027, 2028 geschätzt.
Wer, wer schätzt denn sowas?
Das ist mein Homemade Bellows-System mit einem...
Warte, warum?
...modernen Twist. Und ich habe es vor einiger Zeit als Experiment...
Wa... wa... äh, aber wieso?
...method of moving air without using fans.
And remarkably, it works fantastically...
Ach, ist das, ist das, hä? Aber, ja, okay, okay, okay, man muss nicht immer hinterfragen, warum.
...able to shift its entire internal volume every second while barely making any noise at all
and being extremely cool to watch.
However, it was...
Ah, gerade beim Mittagessen kann ich auch viel internal volume bei mir shiften.
Gar kein Problem.
...always intended to be more than just a novelty.
So, in this video, I'm going to be putting it to good use
by building it into what it was always designed for.
A high-power PC.
Ich habe einmal ein Video von ihm geguckt on stream und ich fand das Ergebnis nicht, nicht sonderlich praktikabel.
Mal gucken, wie das diesmal ist.
Ich skippe wahrscheinlich, ja, okay.
...sponsored by KiwiCo. More about them later.
Aha, ich dachte, jetzt kann ich gleich skippen, aber das war G-Bait.
Das war, das war Skip, Skip G-Bait.
...in order of how this unique air movement system actually works, as it's fascinating
and it all hinges around the biggest challenge in making it,
which was to get the mover to go back and forth quietly,
as using a motor and pulley system...
Nee, mit praktikabel bei dem letzten Video meine ich nicht,
dass es praktikabel zu bauen ist oder nicht.
Das ist ja...
Das war auch nicht praktikabel zu bauen, aber das war mir egal.
Die Benutzung des Endprodukts fand ich unpraktikabel.
So mit diesen komischen Klappen, die du rausfahren musstest,
dass du ans Laufwerk kommst und sowas.
...out of the question due to the noise that it would generate.
My first attempts were to make a silent linear motor
with some magnets in a tube and some wire coils.
While this did work to some extent, it wasn't particularly successful.
Viel einfacher wär das eigentlich, sich auf Fiverr irgendeinen Inder zu kaufen,
der für ein permanentes Holz bewegt.
Das kostet auf Fiverr...
Ich hab auf Fiverr geguckt, es gibt auf Fiverr Angebote.
I do everything und geht ab 5 Dollar los.
Da kannst du dir auch jemand holen, der dein Brett bewegt im Rechner die ganze Zeit.
...with the movement being juddery and weak.
Alles kein Problem.
However, observing how well the magnets fitted into the tube
inspired me to what would ultimately be the system by which it works,
which is to move a single magnet in the tube back and forth using water.
Oder ich kauf mir zwei Leute, die pusten die ganze Zeit abwechselnd.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Weiß jemand, wieso die, ähm, wie nennt man das?
Der Luftdurchsatz quasi ist zwischen Pusten und nem modernen high-end PC-Lüfter.
Also kann man so viel pusten für kurze Zeit wie nen PC-Lüfter lüftet?
Ich weiß nicht, in welcher Einheit das gemessen wird,
noch in welchem Druck oder wie auch immer.
Kann man nicht. Na gut.
Reverse to make the magnet go back and forth, though, was a real challenge.
And my first attempt involved making a set of homemade solar panels,
with a focus on silent operation with no loud click.
Lungenvolumen liegt bei 6 Litern.
Na gut, die Frage ist, wie schnell kriegst du die 6 Liter rausgepustet?
They worked by using some of the magnets to direct the flow of water.
And at first it looked pretty promising,
as the magnet could be made to go back and forth with the flick of a switch.
And encouraged, I proceeded with making the main enclosure for it,
which was simply made out of painted MDF with some nice glass panels.
Dachtbar.
Meint ihr, der macht die Dinger wirklich selbst?
Oder er hat seine Leute, die das Zeug für ihn machen,
und er baut die dann nur im Video zusammen?
...made out of two sheets of acrylic that were sandwiched together for rigidity.
Noctur 120 mm Lüfter, da macht 100... was? Kubikmeter pro Stunde?
Klingt schon... klingt irgendwie viel.
...with a set of bearings at each end to move it smoothly along a set of glass rods.
Da kannst du ja fast eine Luftmatratze mit aufpumpen.
The ring of magnets in this movers center initially repelled the magnet in the tube
until it was forced within their magnetic field,
at which point it snapped into position and was held there very securely,
locking them together without actually touching.
Unfortunately though, while the direction reversed nicely
thanks to some reed switches triggering a relay,
it overall didn't work very well at all,
with the motion being very weak and slow.
Naja, das Problem ist, dass er ein Loch in der Wand hat.
This was down to the valves simply not being strong enough to overcome the flow of water,
so it was time for a rethink,
and essentially the project was rescued by these cheap little water pumps.
You see, unlike many pumps, these having no inter...
Was hat das jetzt so vor allem mal mit Wasser zu tun? Eben wollte er doch noch Luft bewegen.
... internal circuitry results in them instantly starting and stopping when provided with power.
So, after stringing a set of them together, with half orientated to pump in one direction...
Jetzt bring ich dich mal durch.
... things were finally looking up,
as they could instantly jet water out with a significant amount of power,
thanks to them all working together.
So, once it was all plumbed up...
Das Wasser bewegt die Magnet?
... and yes, I was pretty excited to see it working at last.
Yes! Yes!
Also, der pumpt hier quasi Wasser rein, das bewegt...
Ich mein, wenn man schon eh ne Pumpe und Gedöns dafür braucht,
macht man das schon.
Man könnte auch einfach ne Wasserkühlung nehmen.
Look at that! Look at that!
So, what's remarkable about this system is how silent it is during use,
and how quickly the mover changes in direction.
This rapid change in direction is thanks to some magnets being positioned at the ends of the tube
that actually oppose the mover,
so it already begins to slow down before the water flow is reversed.
When the flow is triggered to go the other way, its inertia is almost completely preserved,
as it just gets bounced back, following the magnet in the tube.
As everything is magnetically coupled, it all operates smoothly with plenty of shock absorption,
which is amazing to watch.
Wo macht denn denn die Hardware eigentlich hin?
Hier auf dieses Ding? Oder hier unten?
So, a fascinating device to be sure.
But it's using it to cool a PC from one side at a time, passively,
with only to really test out the cooling ability of the below system,
I'm using top-of-the-line components here,
with the rig being based around the very powerful AMD 5950X and a Zotac RTX 3080.
At the time of making this video, graphics cards are in short supply,
so a big shout-out to Zotac for sending this over to the below.
So that it can be cooled by the bellows though, rather than its original heatsink,
I'm going to replace it with a water block,
and you'll see why this is important in just a moment.
What?
Crucial 2 have sent over one of their new 64GB RAM-Kits...
Das ist kein RGB-RAM.
Das kann schon mal nix werden.
Wobei wir letztens gelernt haben, RGB-RAM ist ja auch schon nicht mehr das Beste.
BGRA-RAM ist das...
...richtig der Shit.
...BGR-RAM.
...3600 MHz.
Perfect for a maxed-out AMD-based build.
Now, to keep the processor cool as well,
I'm using an Alphacool Ice Bear Solo CPU Block,
which amazingly has both a pump and reservoir built into it.
Also gibt's doch ne Wasserkühlung, oder wie?
...making the whole water loop much, much simpler to put together,
as you'll see in a moment.
For the mounting system, I'm using some aluminium right-angle lengths,
and as these are going to be seen, it makes sense to give them a polish.
Believe it or not, this is the first time I've actually used polish on aluminium in a build,
which is super easy to plumb up thanks to the Ice Bear Solo,
taking care of so much of what makes a water loop complicated.
Cyan, magenta, gelb, RAM, das geht nicht,
weil das ist ja additive Farbmischung versus subtraktive Farbmischung,
und RAM leuchtet ja selbst, das heißt, das funktioniert nicht.
Alles klar.
...and once filled up, it's essentially complete with just three pipes required. Easy.
After adding two sheets of acrylic glass to the chamber,
the system can be lowered in place, with a passive PSU...
Aber warum?
...being added to the bottom to power it all.
Wenn das einfach... Ich dachte am Anfang, dass der einfach wild die Luft hin und her schiebt
und dass das kühlt, okay, aber wenn das doch eh einfach nur, sagen wir mal so,
einfach eine Wasserkühlung wird...
Warum nicht einfach eine Wasserkühlung?
So, as you can see, they aesthetically match each other...
Eine ernst gemeinte Frage, was macht eine Wasserkühlung besser als eine normale?
Aus meiner Sicht nichts.
Also, ich bevorzuge ganz normale Luftkühlung schon ewig versus Wasserkühlung.
...which is great. However, they do need to be interfaced together
for the air valve system to work properly.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von diesem Video nicht.
...and I don't know how it happened, but...
Disaster!
The acrylic tube for the magnet has shattered.
Okay, ich muss jetzt mal...
Oh nein!
Ich muss jetzt mal vorspulen, das ist richtig dumm.
...buying a new one.
You see, the magnet...
There is still hope.
Okay.
Alter, wie groß ist denn bitteschön dieses Gehäuse?
...last piece to the puzzle.
What the fuck?
Das ist ja eine Tür!
...puzzle.
The side intake vents.
These again are made out of MDF,
though I've rounded the external side of the vent holes with my router
to make them look a bit nicer.
And after the usual trim-up process,
including some additional foam buffers for silence,
they can be screwed in place along with a top panel to cover the radiator.
Das sieht auch noch zusätzlich richtig hässlich aus, das Ding.
...the world's first breathing PC is complete.
So, with it finally together, it's looking absolutely ginormous.
But, thanks to the glass, it doesn't actually feel too heavy in the room,
because it's somewhat transparent.
Was für ein Schwachsinn.
Anyway, it's going to be really interesting to see whether the bellows are going to be powerful enough
to push the air through the vents and cool down the system.
Ach, das da unten ist quasi sein Wärmetauscher oder was?
Also, oder wie jetzt? Das da oben ist Wasserkühlung.
Hier ist, hier ist, was ist denn das?
Ist hier der Radiator?
Aber dann, da müsste ja hier Luft pusten, dass es hier kühlt oder so.
But, before we try that out and test all sorts of things like thermals,
it's time for a quick ad from this video's...
Also, das hier schiebt quasi Luft hier durch und es kühlt dann,
geht durch die Kühlrippen und kühlt dadurch das Wasser runter.
...sponsor KiwiCo.
KiwiCo makes super cool projects,
that are not only fun,
but has its own future.
For example, we made it all modern,
but what we've been...
...free...
...a grand...
...the rhythmic motion that looks very futuristic.
Ja, tatsächlich, hier, guck.
Hier wird die Luft reingepustet und dann...
Okay, okay, naja.
Wieso steht das? Weil das bei mir auf dem Profil steht
und ich bisher noch keinen Bock hatte, in mein Profil was reinzuschreiben.
Almost like alien technology from...
Das passiert, wenn man zu viel Zeit hat.
Das passiert, wenn man einen YouTube-Channel hat mit...
...solchem Inhalt.
Dann muss man sich halt solche Dinger aus den Fingern saugen.
Übrigens, super hässliche RGB-Beleuchtung ist wahrscheinlich...
Ja, doch.
The way the vents are configured allows for a continual flow of air over the components,
where it then goes through the radiator, into which all of the system's heat is dumped,
and then in turn kept cool by the passing air.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
There is a small drop in this flow,
whenever the mover changes in direction,
but for something that works passively,
it does appear to function surprisingly well.
So all this looks extremely promising and is very cool to watch.
But does it actually keep the system cool?
Well, it's time to do some tests.
Now, I've got my monitor here and I'm just going to plug it in.
Das ist aber auch mal hier Ultra-Widescreen.
...with the cables I've already prepared.
So, the first thing I'm going to do is slam it with Prime95,
which should stress the CPU, which is again a 5950X,
to its absolute limit and generate a lot of heat.
So let's see how this goes.
Kann er auch die Geschwindigkeit regeln, dass das mehr, dass das schneller, schneller pustet?
Alright, so it's been running for a while now,
and I think the maximum temperature has been reached,
as it is sticking at 60 degrees Celsius.
Das geht.
That's pretty good, especially considering this is a 16-core processor.
So I'm very impressed so far.
But what about the graphics card?
Now, it's worth noting that the graphics card...
Ich meine, die Idee ist nicht schlecht.
Insgesamt ein bisschen...
Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt irgendein Hersteller hingeht und sagt,
hey, so eine geile Idee,
wir werden das jetzt einfach mal serienmäßig was bauen.
Weil das Ding da oben ist eine ganz normale Wasserkühlung anscheinend.
Und hier ist halt der Wärmetauscher oder die Rippen oder so,
man erkennt es nicht so richtig.
Also da spricht eigentlich kaum was dafür.
Man könnte da auch einfach ganz normal Lüfter dran machen.
... kann viel mehr Wärme generieren als eine CPU kann.
Also das wird interessant werden.
Unglaublich, die Temperaturen der Grafikkarte sind genauso beeindruckend,
dass sie sich an einem Maximum von 62°C auswirken,
was es scheint, auf jeden Fall auf jeden Fall auf den System zu schießen.
Für solche mächtigen Komponenten sind diese Ergebnisse...
Äh, mal was anderes.
Das hier ist doch geschlossen, ne?
Sonst würde es ja mit dem Druck überhaupt nicht hinhauen.
Es muss ja geschlossen sein, so.
Äh...
Wie kriegt der da neue Luft rein?
Weil das wärmt sich doch auf.
Also wenn er das mal angenommen,
da hat das jetzt irgendwie zwei Tage am Stück laufen.
Das...
Oder hat der hier irgendwelche Ventile,
dass das quasi hier nachzieht,
so dass das quasi hier rauspustet.
Ach, der zieht das hier rein und pustet das dann da raus oder so.
Ja, dann ist okay, dann funktioniert's.
Ah, der Chat, der Chat hat's wieder verstanden, alles klar.
Ich denke, dass das ist, weil im Praxis das Bellows-System
das Luft durch die Radiator-Venteile mehr effektiv sein kann,
wenn man es direkt an es montiert.
Das hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten, das stimmt.
Und doch, weil...
Das stellt das Clown persönlich, ja.
Das macht er ja eigentlich.
Es gibt viel Raum für Verbesserungen von diesem initialen Prototyp.
Okay, also...
Oh ja, warte mal, das müssen wir noch hören.
Die Bellows sind nicht so enttäuschend,
aber die Luftventile schlagen wenig,
die ich weiter reduzieren möchte,
indem ich die Bellows-Venteile mit kleinen,
enttäuschenden Magneten stattfinde,
um sie komplett sauber zu machen.
Auch so ist es ein ziemlich entspannender Geräusch
und hat eine friedliche Qualität.
Es hört sich an wie eine entfernte Sirene aus Half-Life.
Ich denke, diese Leistungsresultate
sind eigentlich ziemlich gut,
weil das im Grunde ein Fan-Verteiler ist.
Und ich weiß, dass es riesig ist...
Jetzt überleg dir mal,
jemand würde so einen fetten Lüfter nehmen,
also man muss sich das mal vorstellen,
man muss sich auch den Platzbedarf sich angucken.
Jemand nimmt quasi einen...
Was ist denn das?
60 cm Lüfter
und macht das einfach auf so einen Wärmetauscher drauf.
Das könntest du auch nahezu unhörbar laufen lassen
und würde es auch super kühlen.
Nee, praktisch ist es nicht.
Ich finde die Idee cool.
Also...
Die Idee ist cool, es funktioniert.
Aber es gibt sicherlich noch 50 weitere,
wenn es mir reicht, coole Cooling-Systems,
die funktionieren,
die aber nicht wirklich praktikabel sind.
Ich meine, ich könnte auch einfach im Flugzeug rumfliegen
und meinen Wärmetauscher unten aus dem Flugzeug raushängen lassen.
Das hat sicherlich auch ganz guten Airflow.
Das ist aber auch nicht wirklich praktikabel.
Es scheint einfach organisch zu sein.
Und es gibt auch ein paar Varianten,
die random in ihrer Funktion sind,
die es einfach ein bisschen lebendig machen,
was ziemlich seltsam ist.
Aber ja, es ist also nicht super praktisch oder so,
aber es macht definitiv das, was ich mir vorgestellt habe,
nämlich etwas wirklich Unique zu machen.
Aber ja, ich hoffe, ihr habt das Video genossen
und ich hoffe, ihr habt genossen, den Build-Prozess zu sehen.
Du kannst auch mit Flüssigstickstoff, genau.
Wie, das ist nicht praktikabel?
Ich dachte, der Bauer kühlt seine PCs nur mit Flüssigstickstoff.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der überhaupt andere Kühlmittel bei sich zu Hause hat.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als Nächstes an?
Zeig mal her.
Klar habe ich Bilder an der Wand hängen.
Bilder sind äußerst praktikabel.
Was ist denn so eine Bild-Unpraktikabel?
Das ist ein vieriges Holzding mit Bild des Hengst an die Wand.
Das macht genau das, was es soll und ist ziemlich easy.
Was für Bilder? Die von meinem Opa.
Mein Opa hat doch viele Bilder gemalt.
Da hängen hier einige rum.
Habe ich sogar mal ein Video dazu gemacht.
Fuck, ich kann das jetzt hier nicht suchen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das im Stream zeigen darf.
Weil in dem Video sieht man sehr viele nackige Mädels, die der Opa gemalt hat.
Ich glaube, ich habe sogar das Video anlistet gemacht auf YouTube,
weil es...
Ja, ich hatte...
Ich glaube, ich habe das Video an...
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Anlistet auf YouTube gemacht, weil YouTube gesagt hat,
das ist ab 18 Content und es gibt irgendwie Probleme oder sowas.
Richtig hängen geblieben eigentlich, ne?
Ja, nur 18 plus.
Nur 18 plus, Leute.
18 plus Video ist das.
Ich glaube, es ist mein einziges 18 plus Video auf dem Channel.
Gucke, ob ich was zeigen kann.
Nee, nee.
Ich kann es euch nicht zeigen.
Das ist...
Das sind zu viele...
Zu viele nackige Bilder drauf zu sehen.
Das war quasi das HotTube-Stream seiner Zeit.
Nee, aber der hat ja auch viele normale Bilder gemalt.
Da hängen ja einige von rum.
Doch, ich...
Das Video ist noch oben.
Ich habe gerade geguckt.
So, das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Ich glaube ja, dass ich schwach bin.
Ich glaube ja, das ist komplett sinnlos.
Aber warum braucht man eine mit dem...
Eine IoT...
Eine IoT-Matratze?
Das möchte ich mir jetzt mal erklären lassen.
Should your mattress be connected to the Internet?
Today on the hookup we're going to take a look at the 8SleepPod Pro and figure out if it can live up to its nearly $3000 price tag and the fact that you have to connect your mattress to the Internet.
Warum?
Na gut, weil es geht und weil es wahrscheinlich irgendeine App gibt, die, keine Ahnung, Schlafbewegungen aufzeichnet oder keine Ahnung.
Fair warning, this video is probably going to be really different from the other reviews of the 8SleepPod Pro.
Sagen wir mal so, eine Matratze mit eingebauter Klimaanlage wäre schon cool, gerade wenn es so warm ist.
...that you can find on YouTube, which are mostly done by mattress experts and mattress-specific channels.
But if you've never heard of them before, 8Sleep's two main products are the Pod Pro and Pod Pro Cover.
The Pod Pro...
Moment.
Wait a minute.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Es ist eine Matratze mit...
Nee, das ist...
Man kann das halt in Raten bezahlen, ne?
Ich dachte, das ist eine Matratze mit einem Monats-Abo.
Das wäre ja noch schöner.
Okay.
Ich kann entweder einmalig bezahlen, 3000 Dollar oder monatlich 82 Dollar.
Sag mal...
Also...
Naja.
Okay.
Man muss Prioritäten setzen, ja?
Ist eigentlich laut genug?
Ja, es war laut genug.
Aha.
Also es ist für euch.
Also, es ist für euch.
Okay, ich hab eine Frage, die wir gerne mal mit dir beantworten können.
Gibt es, wie man sagt, ein Modell mit einem Modell, das eine Seite maximal Gas anbaut und die andere
Seite maximal cool macht und mehr als eine 25-Degrenzen-Geräte erzeugt, das ist ziemlich beeindruckt.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch in der ordentlichen Einheit?
91 Grad, was ist das?
32 Grad.
So, und das andere, aber was?
65, 18 Grad.
Okay.
Das ist einfach nur mal halb so warm.
Kekona units, ja.
... das ist das gleiche Ding, aber du hast deine eigene Matratze.
Ja.
Gibt es eine Custom-Firmware dafür?
Ja, Florian, das stimmt.
BTU ist immer noch die beste Einheit.
BTU pro Stunde.
Also BTU ist wirklich
Best-of-Bullshit-Einheiten.
BTU ist die Menge an
Wärmeenergie, die es braucht,
um ein britisches Pfund Wasser
um ein Grad Fahrenheit
zu erwärmen.
Ein britisches Pfund,
wohlgemerkt, ja.
Das ist die schlimmste Einheit
aller Zeiten.
Was?
Ich meine,
wollen die ernsthaft,
musste man da ernsthaft ursprünglich
3000 Euro für ausgeben
und einen Monatsbeitrag bezahlen?
Das ist doch nicht denen ernst gewesen.
Das ist doch nicht mal ganz dicht.
Ja.
Du brauchst, was weiß ich, einen MMO und jetzt noch neuerdings deine Matratze.
Und, und, wo bloß Twitch Prime nicht zu vergessen.
Plus, äh, natürlich OnlyFans, logischerweise.
Ja, Chat, natürlich, ich seh schon.
Da muss man natürlich zu den Monatsausgaben dabei rechnen.
Noch 20 OnlyFans-Accounts.
Ich, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe, ich habe nicht mal einen OnlyFans-Account, mit dem ich OnlyFans subscribe, also ich, ich, ich habe nicht eine OnlyFans-Subscription.
Ich seh das auch nicht ein.
Nicht Kappa! Wirklich!
Warum glaubt, Chat, warum glaubt ihr mir das nicht?
So, ich hab keine OnlyFans, äh, Subscriptions.
Ja, ja.
Also, ich bin der Ansicht, wenn man eine intelligente oder wie auch immer, äh, Smart-Matratze verkauft, dann sollte man auch garantieren, dass die so lange funktioniert.
Ich meine, dass ne Matratze an sich länger als zwei Jahre hält, sollte ja wohl selbstverständlich sein.
Ja, ja.
Aber was bringt es mir, wenn ich ne 3000 Euro superintelligente Matratze kaufe und die nach zwei Jahren kaputt ist und es einfach nur ne normale Matratze ist?
Was hast du eigentlich für einen komischen Fullscreen?
Äh, was ist an meinem Fullscreen komisch?
Einheitentierliste.
Leute, die wichtigste Einheit ist Sekunde.
Sekunde.
Wenn du Sekunde, wenn du Sekunde hast, kannst du fast alles andere draus machen.
Ist es jemals ein guter Grund, dass Unternehmen Daten über dich sammeln?
Und meine Ansichten auf diesen Thema sind viel mehr liberal.
Sammeln von Daten war immer wichtig in der Wissenschaft und Technologie.
Und Maschinenlernung hat es noch immer wichtiger gemacht.
Nicht nur hat die Technologie die Daten einfacher gemacht, um sie zu sammeln und zu teilen, aber der Einfluss dieser Daten ist jetzt noch mehr bedeutend, dass Computer Korrelationen finden können, die in Billionen von Datenpunkten verbunden sind.
Ja.
Vorher, um Informationen über Schlaf zu sammeln,
Ja, gut, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, ihr wollt mir jetzt nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass die Matratze das gleiche macht wie irgendein Schlaflabor, oder?
Also, so, so, also, das, ja.
... expensive lab with lots of sensors hooked to them, which, while definitely helpful, adds a significant amount of confounding variables to the data that's being collected.
However, by putting sensors in consumer devices inside tens of thousands of households...
Die, die Matratze kann ja wohl kaum mein, äh, also was ja so Schlaflabore machen, ist zum Beispiel, die messen auch, wie viel Sauerstoff in deiner Atemluft und so weiter.
Die, die Matratze kann ja wohl kaum mein, äh, also was ja so Schlaflobore machen, ist zum Beispiel, die messen auch, wie viel Sauerstoff in deiner Atemluft und so weiter.
... was drin ist nachts und ob du Luft anhältst und so, das kann die Matratze alles nicht messen.
... data in a week than humanity has in the previous 50 years of research.
Ist das ein Produktplacement? Nein?
Unfortunately, I think lots of people get hung up on data collection, as if there's always such a evil plot to manipulate your thoughts and buying data.
Ist es nicht? Hätte ich auch gedacht, aber der ist da immer sehr gewissenhaft mit Kennzeichen und es steht nirgendwo, ist es nicht?
Data collection doesn't have to be bad.
Ich glaube, er möchte uns jetzt erklären, warum es nicht schlimm ist, wenn man eine mit der Cloud verbundene, dauer-online, äh, online-seiende Matratze hat.
... from 8sleep on the phone, he really convinced me that 8sleep is on the right path.
Moment, Moment, ist das, ist das, ist, möchten die uns sagen, sie haben AI-gesteuerte Matratzentemperatur?
Oh Mann! AI-gesteuerte...
Also man könnte auch hingehen und einfach einen Sensor einbauen und versuchen, die Körpertemperatur auf so einem Niveau zu halten oder sowas, aber das muss natürlich...
... 6,5 Terabyte trained data sein, dass man, äh, Smart Temp AI hat.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch Blockchain eingebaut.
... doesn't have to be bad.
When I spoke to the marketing manager from 8sleep on the phone, he really convinced me that 8sleep is on the right path.
He said that 8sleep has two big goals.
One immediate goal is to do something called sleep compression, which basically means sleeping more in less time.
Or increasing the effectiveness of your sleep by targeting...
Ist das nicht...
... ein Widerspruch in sich?
Sleeping more in less time?
Also mir ist klar, was sie damit meinen.
Du liegst 8 Stunden im Bett und schläfst davor nur die Hälfte, oder du liegst 4 Stunden im Bett und schläfst alle 4, ist schon klar, aber an sich, dieser Satz ist...
... different sleep stages.
The 8sleep Pod Pro is packed with sensors to monitor your sleep progress, and the aim is to figure out how to modify your sleeping environment to direct you from a less effective sleep stage into a better one.
Sleep Speed Run.
Die längere Zielgruppe war es, diese Sensoren und Daten zu nutzen, um die Krankheiten zu beurteilen, bevor sie sogar passieren.
Sie beurteilen die Anzeichen in einen medizinischen Pod, der sich einsteigen muss.
Natürlich. Moment, Moment, Moment. Davon habe ich doch schon meine iWatch. Meine Apple Watch. Meine Apple Watch sagt doch auch, wenn ich schwanger bin, dass ich jetzt ins Krankenhaus muss, weil das Kind auf die Welt kommt.
Weil das merke ich ja vorher nicht. Das geht nur, wenn ich eine Apple Watch habe.
Nur auf einer viel kürzerem Niveau.
Stattdessen.
Die Methode, wie man sich vor 6-10 Stunden pro Tag aufwâcht, kann viele Datenkollektionen erzielen.
Und in einem Weltraum, in dem große Daten und machine learning täglich erhöht werden können, ist das Konzept, Korrelationen zwischen den Kacken des Schleusens zu finden und verschiedenen Krankheiten, nicht alles etwas mit iWatch abzuwägen.
Sie sehen, das ist stimmt.
Das ist schlimm.
Das ist nicht klar, dass man das machen kann, aber da brauchst du die Sensoren für.
Also eine Matratze bezweifle ich, dass die messen kann, wie man das Sauerstoffgehalt in meinem Blut oder in meiner Atemkörpercentrum ist.
Luft ist. Und wenn sie das kann, würde ich mich eher fragen, warum kann sie das?
Und sobald der Anbieter dicht macht, funktioniert deine Matratze nicht mehr.
Aber auch, um sich einen kompetitiven Vorteil zu geben, in einem Markt, der bereits sehr saturiert ist.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht überrascht werden, dass der 8sleep-Pod keine Krankheiten
diagnostizieren kann.
Und die Statistiken, die es dir gibt, sind mit Warnungen, wie alle Menschen anders sind,
und dass deine Statistiken nicht zu einer Standard-Range generalisiert werden können.
Zumindest noch nicht.
Aber die Daten, die direkt von der Matratze gekauft werden, und eine große Teil der 8sleep-App
konzentriert sich auf dich, deine Feedback zu geben.
Du musst es helfen, es dir zu helfen.
Es wird dir Fragen über deine letzte Schlafsession fragen, wie war die
Temperatur?
War die Temperatur zu heiß während deiner Rezension?
Was ich ehrlich gesagt finde, ziemlich unmöglich zu beantworten, weil, du weißt, ich war
ein 8sleeper.
Aber ich werde weiterhin das Beste tun, was ich kann.
Je mehr Daten sie bekommen, desto besser wird die 8sleep-App nicht nur dafür helfen,
dass ich schlafen kann, sondern jeder andere 8sleep-Kunden wird auch dafür profitieren.
Aber lass uns ehrlich sein.
Wisst ihr, wie das auf mich wirkt?
Die haben ein eigentlich ganz cooles Produkt gebaut, eine Matratze, die die Temperatur
regeln kann, und flanschen da jetzt so viel drauf an, dass es sich nach super High-Tech
Science-Fiction-Shit anhört.
Was es eigentlich gar nicht ist.
Sie haben eine Matratze gebaut, die man Temperatur regulieren kann, das ist an sich schon eine
coole Geschichte, wird aus meiner Sicht auch vollkommen ausreichen.
Aber jetzt versucht man da jetzt, diesem Produkt noch tausend Fähigkeiten anzudichten.
Ich will 3.000 Dollar für etwas bezahlen, das in der Zukunft funktionieren könnte.
Also die große Frage ist, funktioniert es jetzt?
Und für mich ist die Antwort ja.
Ohne zu viel Details über meine Probleme zu gehen.
Ich bin kein guter Schlauer und habe es schon mehr als 20 Jahre nicht gemacht.
Für jede Art und Weise habe ich eine schlechte Zirkulation in meinen Beinen und wenn ich
...
Time to fall asleep?
Drei Minuten?
What the fuck?
Ist der Schein tot, wenn er ins Bett fällt, oder was?
In drei Minuten habe ich mich noch nicht mal so hingelegt, dass ich schlafen könnte.
... get cold, they are physically incapable of warming themselves back up.
My solution to this problem in the past has been electric heating blankets that I've automated
in various ways.
And overall, the solution worked pretty well.
Also, I'm not a good sleeper.
Other than the fact that they constantly need to be positioned into the perfect place.
So I find myself fiddling with them almost every night.
Lots of people are hot sleepers and will use the 8sleep pod to cool them down at night,
which it can definitely do.
But my temperature curve, which the 8sleep calls the autopilot, is always set to positive
temperatures.
When I did my initial setup, the app told me that people like me fall asleep best at
plus zero temperature and then minus one during the night.
And in the interest of science, I decided to give it a shot.
And I barely slept at all that night.
Feeling like I was freezing to death.
But now that I've got it dialed into my personal curve, I literally haven't slept this well
in 20 years.
As I've said, I've also answered a lot of questions in the app about how I sleep.
Es wäre auch möglich, dass es einfach daran liegt, dass wenn es zu warm ist, dass man
nicht ordentlich, ordentlich, keine Ahnung wie es bei ihm ist.
So maybe the next time a person like me loads up the 8sleep app, it won't try to freeze
them to death on their first night.
Okay, enough about me.
Let's take a closer look at the mattress.
It's got a base station that's filled with water and some hydrogen peroxide.
Sieht aus wie so eine Staubsauger-Roboter-Entleerungsstation.
And an umbilical cord that connects the topper to the main unit.
The main unit obviously has a pump and some equipment to heat and cool the water, but
it's nearly silent and I've never heard it over the sound of our fan.
This is the sound of the 8sleep set to maximum cool temperature.
Also, ich würde das hören.
As I mentioned before, the mattress can be set to arbitrary temperature.
Units of minus ten to plus ten.
And I've seen other reviews mention that the mattress can go as low as 55 degrees Fahrenheit
and minus 10.
Moment, das war.
Welche Einheit ist das jetzt?
You mentioned that the mattress can go as low as 55 degrees Fahrenheit and as high as 110
degrees.
I wasn't able to achieve those extremes in my testing, but I can confirm that setting
the temperature to minus ten would be what I classify as minus 10 zur Raumtemperatur.
Aber was Fahrenheit?
Oder?
I'm not sure that the actual numbers matter all that much.
As I mentioned, throughout the night your mattress can change its temperature to modify
your sleep patterns, but it also has a scheduling feature to allow you to always have the bed
ready for you at your daily bedtime.
There are four temperature stages defined in the 8sleeps autopilot curve.
The first is your initial temperature, or what you want the bed to feel like when you
first get in.
The second is your deep sleep, which is generally the first stage of sleep that you fall into
at the beginning of the night.
And then after that is your REM temperature.
With autopilot enabled.
The 8sleep will tweak these values using your data to provide you with the best night's
sleep.
If you don't want it to do that, you can set it to manual mode and define your own temperatures.
The last temperature that you can set is your wake-up temperature.
For me, a gradual heating of the bed in the morning will wake me up naturally.
It's a weird subconscious thing, and having the 8sleep for about two months now, I've
pretty much forgotten that it's even a setting, and I just wake up naturally around the same
time every day.
I don't want to wake up without any traditional alarm, just from a few degrees of temperature
variation in the mattress.
There's also the option to have your side of the mattress vibrate either lightly or
violently, but I found even the lightest vibration to be pretty jarring, and it wasn't
necessary for me.
If you do have trouble waking up in the morning, I can pretty much guarantee that you will
not sleep through this setting.
My only gripe about the wake-up temperature is that it tends to wake me up too early.
Both my wife and I agreed that we had to set the wake-up time at least 15 minutes after
we actually wanted to wake up, because the warming is too effective.
And that leads me to my next gripe.
As a home automation guy, I naturally wanted to use some of the data collected by the smart
mattress in automations for my home.
Unfortunately, 8sleep hasn't made it easy to use this data in any meaningful way.
There's an Amazon Echo skill, where you can ask your devices to read your sleep report
and turn on the sleep pods heating or cooling, but it can't be used with routines, so there's
no way to automate those functions.
8sleep also has an IFTTT channel, but the only actions available are to set the temperature,
turn the warming on or off, or turn off the alarm.
Yeah, the data reading would be pretty cool, but they don't want to give it away, they
just want to collect the data and don't want you to do anything with it, so no, no, no.
The only triggers are pressing a button in the app and using the 8sleep's wake-up alarm.
Things like sleep stage and most importantly bad...
There's no reason at all why this thing necessarily needs cloud connection, except for their
co-imagined history of disease detection and AI and whatever else.
I don't know.
It's not my thing.
Last but not least, even though the main way you interact with Sleep Pod is through
the iOS app, there is no option to sync the iOS sleep schedule with the 8 app or vice
versa, and there's no HomeKit functionality for the 8sleep Pro at all.
For more advanced automators, there is a Home Assistant integration that uses cloud polling
to get things like sleep stage, sleep score, bed temperature, and bed status, but unfortunately
the most obviously useful metric to me, bed presence, doesn't seem to work and up-to-date
Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Dann bauen sie ein Produkt, was an sich ja ganz cool ist.
Ich meine, eine temperaturgeregelte Matratze lassen wir mit diesem ganzen AI-Schwachsinn und sowas weg.
Ist ja ein cooles Ding, aber dann kannst du es praktisch in nichts Gescheites integrieren.
Das ist doch alles, das ist doch sowas Halbherziges wieder.
Ist die 8SleepPod Pro wert für 3.000 Dollar?
Wenn du es mit einer hochwertigen Matratze wie der von Casper vergleichst,
kannst du viel mehr als 2.000 Euro für nur eine Matratze bezahlen, ohne irgendeine smarte Funktionalität.
Also, vielleicht sollten wir uns die Frage stellen, ist die 8SleepPod Pro wert für ein extra 1.000 Dollar mehr als eine Standardmatratze?
Und um das zu beantworten, musst du dir ein paar Fragen stellen.
Zuerst, ist die Temperaturkontrolle negativ auf dein Leben zu verursachen?
Wenn ja, kann ich zu dem Eintrag, dass die 8SleepPod Pro alle meine Temperaturprobleme verhindert hat,
ohne all die Fiddlung, die ich mit einem Nachttagsheatpad tun musste.
Zudem musst du dich fragen, ob du okay bist mit der Möglichkeit,
diese smarte Funktionalität komplett zu verlieren.
8Sleep sieht nicht so aus, als würde sie aus dem Geschäft gehen,
aber wenn sie es tun und sie sind...
Ja.
Das ist das hauptsächliche Problem.
Revolutionize Sleep Science jetzt.
Es ist eine temperaturgeregelte Matratze, das ist ein cooles Produkt,
aber das, was die da drumherum stricken, finde ich, ist einfach wieder zu aufgesetzt.
Ja.
Und ich wünschte, dass sie eine lokale Kontrolloption hatten.
Nur, wenn das 8SleepPod Pro runtergeht.
8Sleep hat mir diese Matratze für die Revisierung ermöglicht,
aber kein anderes Geld hat sich geändert und sie hatten keine editorialen Inhalte im Video.
Wenn dieses Video dir helfen konnte, zu entscheiden, ob das 8SleepPod Pro für dich gut ist...
Hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt.
Wie gesagt, ich finde das Produkt an sich nice, ja, ein 10-Pod, aber das, was sie sich da drumherum zusammendichten, nee.
Wirklich nicht.
Muss echt nicht sein.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Was Activate... Warum hab ich denn das ausgewählt?
Wahrscheinlich langweilig.
Epische Mittelalter-Schlachten ewig nicht mehr gespielt.
Das wollte ich mir holen, ich fand den ersten Teil wirklich extrem cool.
Das gucken wir jetzt auch nicht.
Gun-Safe! Kokona-Time! Jawoll!
Wir brauchen sowas ja nicht.
Aber in Amis ist natürlich so ein Gun-Safe, das ist wichtig.
This is the Lockpicking Lawyer, and what I have for you today is a Sully brand biometric Gun-Safe.
This is sold on Amazon for $80.
And to its credit, it seems to be beefier than...
Okay, das Video geht 1,53, da wackelt es zweimal dran und es ist offen.
...comparable products.
The lockbox has three design methods of entry. Easy. Easy, also wackeln!
You can enter a numeric code.
In this case I have it set to 1, 2, 3, 4.
You can use the biometric fingerprint sensor.
Or you can also use the mechanical backup lock that's on the front.
Und das Lock ist wahrscheinlich so schlecht, dass er zweimal wackeln und es ist offen.
It takes this unusual two-sided nine-pin key.
Now, this unusual key might be intimidating.
Find ich auch. Sieht billig aus, das Ding.
So irgendwie einmal zu fest drauf gehauen und es ist auf hier vorne.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist es das gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das Einfachste ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das, was er jetzt macht.
Einfach, wenn du krasse Lockpicking-Skills hast wie er.
Dreimal wackeln und es ist offen.
...to some pickers just because of the high pin count.
...and strange design.
But the build quality and internal tolerances of the lock are so poor...
Ah, ist doch schlecht.
...that this is quite literally hard not to open if you insert the picks correctly.
Let me show you just how bad it is.
Let's do that a few more times so you can see it was not a fluke.
Okay, das ist echt schlecht.
...and one last time.
Okay, folks, this is the kind of flaw that's revealed by the most basic of testing.
So I have to conclude that this either wasn't tested or it was and they didn't care.
Either way, this is not a product that I would trust to stop a curious adolescent.
In any case, that's all I have for you today.
If you do have any questions or comments about this, please put them below.
If you liked this video and would like to see more like it, please subscribe.
Das ist schneller, das ist schneller als wenn du den originalen Schlüssel hast.
...schneller als wenn du den originalen Schlüssel nimmst.
Das musst du auch erstmal hinkriegen, dass du schneller öffnest als mit dem originalen Schlüssel.
Das ist das amerikanischste Video, das ich je gesehen habe.
Was ist das denn?
Irgendeine Magnethaltung, Pistolenmagnethaltung fürs Auto.
Ja, gut.
Freedom, das braucht man.
Natürlich.
Unglaub-uglaublich wichtig.
Also...
Wenn man nicht seine G18 gleich mal griffbereit hat im Auto,
dann geht da mal ganz schnell was in die Hose, ja?
Ist auch eine G18, oder?
Na, das jetzt nicht, aber das davor ist eine G18, oder?
Das da, das ist auch eine G18, oder?
Zu meinen Battlefield-Kenntnissen sagen wir, das ist eine G18.
Das ist jetzt was anderes.
Aber warum?
Warum, warum, haben die, ist, ist das, ist das bei den Amis wirklich so,
dass die permanent in Straßenschießereien geraten,
dass du on, on the fly am Fahrersitz deine Pistole griffbereit haben musst?
Die Like-Anzahl, boah, Alter.
Das norddeutsche Unternehmer regt sich auf.
Ist das ein, ist, ist das ein, ist das ein Legit-Video, oder ist das ein Fake-Video?
Also ist das, ist das wirklich ein norddeutscher Unternehmer,
oder jemand, der tut, als wäre es ein norddeutscher Unternehmer?
Das ist mega, okay, okay, mal gucken.
Wenn der Chat, wenn der Chat das sagt.
Technisch durchdacht ist und funktioniert.
Und da funktioniert ein Bärchen, oder ein Einhorn, oder ein Regenbogen,
der kommt, der kommt nicht auf meine Klamotte, das gibt's nicht.
Das, das machen wir nicht, okay, da kann ich mich nicht mehr anfreunden.
Ja, kann er, kann er ziehen, was er will.
Sie brauchen dringend mehr Platz zum Produzieren.
Und.
Eigentlich hätten Sie den ja auch, im alten Kuhstall.
Zwei davon gehören zum Anwesen.
Ich würde gerne halt hier das Dach in Ordnung bringen,
einen vernünftigen Estrich machen, und dann könnten wir hier halt produzieren.
Das Ding ist, ich brauche hier.
Das Dach sieht fast so gut aus wie mal ursprünglich in meiner Garage.
Und dann könnten wir hier halt produzieren.
Das Ding ist, ich brauche hier, weil wir sind im Außenbereich,
da brauche ich eine, möchte eine, muss eine Umnutzung machen,
weil das ist ja hier landwirtschaftlich genutzt, sieht man ja.
Sieht man ja, okay, da brauche ich also eine Umnutzung.
Und die Umnutzung findet auf dem Formular vom Bauantrag statt.
Das heißt also, es ist ein Bauantrag und Bauantrag im Außenbereich.
Da wird das mal abgelehnt.
Jetzt soll das Amt Neukloster den Flächennutzungsplan ändern.
Ja, Bürokratie ist schon was Tolles.
Soll die Gemeinde einen Bebauungsplan machen und dann kann ich einen Bauantrag stellen.
Verstehst du?
Aber die ganzen Planer, die sich natürlich darüber freuen, über die Regelung bezahle ich.
Kann ich aber nicht.
Ich meine, ich habe auch keinen Dukaten.
Esel.
Der.
Der Geld scheißt oder was.
Wie stellen die sich denn sowas vor?
Das ist ganz einfach.
Politischer Wille ist nicht da, dass ich hier produzieren kann.
Weißt du, was die zu mir sagen?
Die sagen zu mir, wir wollen die Zersiedelung des ländlichen Raumes aufhalten.
Hier oben, Alter.
Guck doch mal raus.
Wenn du hier raus...
Aber alles kein Problem.
Deutschland wird der Leitmarkt für Computerspiele in Zukunft.
Das ist genauso realistisch.
Wenn du hier rausguckst, da kannst du bis zum Horizont, geht ein Feld.
Und wenn du...
Wenn du an dem Horizont stehst, da kannst du noch mal bis zum Horizont gehen.
Ist immer noch das gleiche Feld.
Ja, hat der Recht.
Das ist Zersiedelung, bitte.
Was war Münsterland?
Meine Frau kommt aus dem Münsterland.
Da ist Zersiedelung.
Ja, da kann man das so sehen, ja.
Aber das ist schön.
Das ist eine schöne Landschaft.
Und hier ist Agrarwüste.
Und wenn einer kommt und möchte halt irgendwelche alten Ställe irgendwie nutzen...
Also, tut mir leid.
Und dann haben sie mir jetzt einen Verwaltungslotsen.
Ein Verwaltungslotsen, der mich durch die Stromschnellen...
Ja gut, das brauchst du ja auch, sonst blickst du ja...
Das geht ja auch nicht mehr.
... der unteren Verwaltungsbehörde.
Ey Leute, hört euch doch mal selber...
Da muss man sich...
Hält man sich also selber zu?
Wenn ich mit Abitur nicht mehr in der Lage bin,
mich durch die Stromschnellen meiner Verwaltung, die ich bezahle, die für mich da ist...
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Das ist das Problem.
Die sollte eigentlich...
Eigentlich sollte...
Sollten, sagen wir mal so, Behörden und...
Richtigen...
Sollten eigentlich dafür da sein, nicht die Sache unnötig komplizierter zu machen,
sondern, dass es eine klare Linie, eine klare Struktur gibt,
dass es die Sache eigentlich von der Idee her einfacher und durchschaubarer macht.
Nachvollziehbarer macht.
Es ist aber mittlerweile so ausgeartet in vielen Bereichen, dass du es komplett vergessen kannst.
... selber durchzulavieren.
Ja, da können wir aufhören.
Da können wir es lassen.
Also, Leute, ich hab Bock, was anzupacken.
Ich hab Bock.
Ich hab Bock, die Welt zu verbessern.
Aber irgendwer muss auch mitmachen.
Ansonsten können wir es lassen.
Und jetzt sitzen wir da in einer Produktionshalle, nicht genehmigt, illegal.
Und wir haben einen Haufen solcher...
Also, es sind...
Wir wollen unbedingt, dass die Leute vom Land in die Stadt ziehen.
Da haben sie mir angeboten, bei Wismar...
Da saß der Bürgermeister hier neben mir.
Da hatten wir einen Termin bei der Landräte.
Da haben sie gesagt,
da gehen sie doch nach Wismar.
Da haben wir auf der grünen Wiese,
da ist eine grüne Wiese,
da haben wir...
Vor allem, wo ist...
Wo ist...
Eigentlich, es gibt ja gar kein Problem in dem Sinne.
Also, eigentlich ist die Sache vom Ansatz her ziemlich easy.
Da ist ein Gebiet erschlossen.
Da können sie eine Metallhalle bauen.
Da können wir auch...
Die können wir...
Können wir ihnen einen Flyer geben.
Der baut ihnen da die Metallhalle hin.
Zack, zack, fertig.
Können wir sie noch fördern?
Fördern wir ihn noch?
Nee, will ich nicht.
Hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Was mach ich denn dann mit dieser Immobilie?
Die zerfällt dann, oder was?
Wer kommt denn?
Frage ich mich.
Also, kann ich nicht...
Kann ich nicht begreifen.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Ich meine, guck mal hier.
Guck mal hier.
Das musst du dir mal angucken.
Da hat sich mal einer hingestellt
und hat den Stein...
Der ist ja so nicht gewachsen.
Hat sich hingestellt mit Hammer und Meißel
und hat den Stein hier eckig geschlagen.
Vor 200 Jahren.
Und da baue ich mir eine Halle auf der grünen Wiese aus Blech?
Das stimmt schon.
Da hat er recht.
Am Abfuck sind wir.
Und die Leute, die sowas entscheiden,
das sind ja keine Bauingenieure oder so.
Die Leute, die sowas...
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was er sagt,
aber die Leute, die sowas entscheiden,
sind erstens Leute, die davon keine Ahnung haben.
Das ist aber gar nicht so sehr das Problem.
Das eigentliche Problem ist,
das sind Leute, denen es scheißegal ist.
Die keinerlei persönliches Interesse daran haben,
noch irgendwie bei schlechten Entscheidungen fürchten müssen,
dass es...
dass es eine persönliche Auswirkung für sie hat.
Leute, die haben Verwaltung, haben die gelernt.
Verwaltung.
Das sind vom Beruf Verwalter.
Die verwalten unseren Reichtum.
Ich meine, es ist halt so...
Also es geht für ein paar.
Aber wir können nicht alle mit einem MacBook und einem Chai Latte
in Berlin in einem Coworking Space sitzen
und die 10. Dating App erfinden.
Es gibt auch ein paar Leute,
die irgendwas anfassen müssen
und sich die Hände schmutzig machen.
Ansonsten geht es halt nicht.
Okay?
Das funktioniert anders.
Und wir machen halt Realwirtschaft.
Das heißt, wir haben mit Produkten,
mit Sachen, mit Materie zu tun.
Und dafür brauchen wir nur mal Platz.
Das ist doch nicht...
Das kann man doch verstehen, oder nicht?
Ja.
Da scheiß ich auf die scheiß Glasfaser drauf.
Ich brauche Platz.
Auf Glasfaser scheiß ich nicht.
Das muss zusätzlich auch noch hin.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Also kann ich komplett nachvollziehen.
Wir brauchen 5G.
Für die Entwicklung des ländlichen Raumes brauchen wir 5G.
Boah, Alter.
Ich kriege eins zu viel.
Ja gut, das eine ist,
man braucht das alles.
Oh, der Typ ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Ja.
Er hat ja nicht Unrecht, ja.
Aber 5G und Glasfaser ist ja eine Sache,
die kannst du trotzdem noch machen.
Soll ich euch mal was erzählen,
dass das alles echt nicht so einfach ist?
Stellt euch vor,
ihr habt einen Baum in eurem Garten stehen
und ihr wollt den Baum wegmachen.
Meint ihr,
ihr dürft einfach in euren eigenen Garten,
gehen und euren eigenen Baum umhacken?
Nein.
Natürlich nicht.
Das geht nicht.
So, das heißt,
du musst erst mal
einen Antrag stellen.
Ich frage mich nicht mal, wie der Kram heißt.
Du musst einen Antrag stellen,
dass du deinen...
Genau, das kommt nämlich auch noch dabei.
Du musst einen Antrag stellen,
dass du den Baum fällen darfst.
Dann muss erst mal geguckt werden,
dass es die richtige Zeit ist,
weil du darfst Bäume,
also ab einem gewissen Datum nicht mehr fällen.
So, dann kommt irgendein Typ vorbei
und guckt sich den Baum an.
Und dann entscheidet vielleicht mal irgendjemand,
ob du deinen eigenen Baum
auf deinem eigenen Grundstück fällen darfst.
So.
Und dann kommen sie noch auf die Idee
und sagen, ja,
es gibt aber noch ein paar Auflagen.
Zum Beispiel,
wenn du jetzt einen Baum fällst,
dann bist du verpflichtet dazu,
einen neuen Baum zu fällen.
Also, sprich,
wenn ich jetzt einen großen Baum fälle bei mir im...
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wenn ich jetzt einen großen Baum bei mir fälle im Garten,
dann muss ich einen kleinen Baum neu pflanzen.
Habe ich gemacht.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Es gibt ja übrigens auch genaue Auflagen,
was das sein muss und was es nicht sein darf.
Und jetzt ist es so,
du kannst nicht einfach
den Baum fällen,
einen neuen Baum pflanzen
und dann sagen, okay, ist gut, habe ich gemacht,
alles klar.
Der Typ kommt vorbei,
guckt, ob du wirklich
den Baum gepflanzt hast,
ob das der richtige Baum ist,
ob das richtig gemacht ist,
ob das alles okay ist.
Und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Es gab wahrscheinlich genug Leute,
die den neuen Baum danach einfach wieder rausgesandt haben.
Der kommt sogar random
nach 1-2 Jahren nochmal vorbei
und guckt, ob der Baum noch steht.
Der neue, den du gepflanzt hast.
Also was ist das denn?
Es ist mein Garten, es ist mein Baum.
Die können mich mal am Arsch lecken.
Ich meine, ich habe es jetzt gemacht,
du hast ja keine andere Chance.
Übrigens, es wird ja noch besser.
Es wird ja noch besser.
Wir haben letztens
noch einen Baum gefällt
und da haben wir auch
wieder einen Antrag gestellt.
Das darf man ja bis
bis zum
Ende Februar oder so darf man das machen.
Und dann haben wir
den Baum fällen lassen
und dann lag dann halt der Baum
gefällt und zerstückelt im Garten rum.
Wenn ihr mal einen großen Baum
im Garten liegen hattet,
das ist ganz schön viel und das ist schwer
und das ist ein großer Haufen.
Also das räumst du nicht einfach mal nebenbei weg.
So, das lag da jetzt, keine Ahnung,
drei, vier Wochen rum
und da habe ich im Internet geguckt,
was gibt es denn so für Unternehmen,
die den Kram abtransportieren.
Ich hätte ich hätte auch
die andere Option gehabt.
Ich hätte es bei eBay Kleinanzeigen
reinstellen können und sagen hier kostenlos
Holz nehmen mit.
So, also.
Ich habe ihn gesucht, aber angerufen
und haben gesagt hier,
wir brauchen Baum, Baum entsorgen.
So, dann kam der Typ und hat das hat
den Baum entsorgt.
Der Kerl selbst war echt super.
Der hat von morgens bis abends geschafft, bis der
Baum weg war.
Aber auf einmal auf einmal steht einer vom Amt vor der Tür.
So random klingelt und es steht einer vom Amt vor der Tür.
Ja, was ist?
Und dann meinte er, er hätte einen Anruf erhalten.
Wir würden hier illegal einen Baum fällen.
Also sprich, irgendjemand hat uns auch noch verpetzt,
was ja gar nicht stimmt.
Wir haben hier gar nicht illegal einen Baum gefällt.
Wir haben den Baum mit Antrag vollkommen korrekt im Februar gefällt.
Der lag dann aber halt ein paar Wochen rum und.
Lag da halt so vor sich hin und irgendjemand hat an dem Tag aus dem Fenster
geguckt und hat festgestellt Oho, die haben einen Baum im Garten liegen.
Da rufe ich doch jetzt mal beim Amt an.
Und dann kam ein Typ vom Amt vorbei und musste sich das nochmal angucken.
Alter, meine Fresse, was?
Nein, scheiße.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist mein Garten.
Das ist mein Baum.
Warum muss ich überhaupt mit irgendjemand auf der Welt reden, dass ich meinen Baum in meinem Garten fällen darf?
Das ist so lächerlich.
Alles ist so.
Es ist nichts passiert.
Der Typ vom Amt vom Türter Typ vom Amt ist vorbei gekommen, hat gesagt, er hat einen Anruf gekriegt, wir hätten illegal einen Baum gefällt, aber wir haben den Baum nicht illegal gefällt.
Hier ist der Antrag alles zugestimmt.
War schon im Februar.
Also okay, dann haut er wieder ab.
Fertig.
Das war's.
Aber irgend irgendeinem Nachbarschaft Opa hat das nicht gefallen, dass wir da Baum abtransportiert haben.
Nee, also so Bürokratische Sachen ist hier echt absolut lächerlich.
Deswegen.
Deswegen muss ich ja auch immer ketten, wenn sie irgendwie erzählen Ja, wir werden führend im Bereich der digitalen Ämter.
Deswegen haben unsere Gesundheitsämter immer noch Faxe zu Corona.
Versteckt, verschickt und so was.
Oder wir werden ein Leitmarkt für Computerspiele oder wir werden das schnellste Internet bekommen.
Oder wir labern immer nur.
Wir schwätzen immer den ganzen Tag, ohne irgendeinen nachhaltigen Plan dafür zu haben, wie man das auch umsetzen kann.
Es wird einfach die letzten, vor allem die letzten 20 Jahre übertrieben.
Übertrieben.
Mein Eindruck zumindest wird einfach zu 95 Prozent geschwätzt und irgendein Datum genannt, was so weit in der Zukunft liegt, dass man das überhaupt nicht mehr mit den Aussagen, die man damals getroffen hat, in Verbindung.
Naja, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Wir zeig mal.
Ja, das haben wir uns angeguckt.
Oh nein, nein, nein.
Please, please, please, please.
Kein, kein, kein Dings jetzt.
Keins ist das.
Das ist mir zu dramatisch.
Das halte ich jetzt nicht aus.
Ok, also was gucken wir uns an?
Warum?
Was will er uns eigentlich mit seinem Windows aktivieren?
Hier sagen, es gibt da mal kurz durch.
So Windows XP was released almost 20 years ago.
Back then they manufactured specific.
Exp.
versions for certain oms musste jemals wirklich schon jemand windows xp aktivieren
windows xp hat man doch dachte ich immer über so einen so einen registry file aktiviert sie
übertreibt man nicht was das für musik im hintergrund das ist bestimmt
ja über die hotline ja das ist das kenne ich noch da musstest du anrufen das kenne
ich noch da musstest du anrufen dann hattest du so einen so einen wie nennt man das so einen
so einen menü roboter dran und muss das dinger durch durch klicken
das geht immer noch
das geht bestimmt immer noch
einen
Ich habe mir mal bei irgendeinem Key-Shop einen eindeutig, oder, naja, was heißt eindeutig, einen, nennen wir es mal, einen relativ sicher ungültigen Key gekauft für, glaube ich, 30 Cent.
Ich wollte einfach mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Das war ein Windows 10 Key.
Da dachte ich mir schon, das kann im Leben nicht funktionieren.
Und du kannst ja bei Windows XP auch so ein Hilfe-Fenster aufmachen, wenn der Key nicht funktioniert.
Da habe ich dem Typ vom Support, da geht dann so eine Chatbox auf, dem Typ vom Support halt geschrieben, ich habe den Key auf Amazon legit erworben.
Und der hat sich aber nicht überreden lassen.
Sie haben gesagt, nein, nein, das ist ein ungültiger Key, ich soll mich an meinen Händler wenden, bla bla bla.
Aber er hat ja anscheinend einen gültigen Key.
Das ist richtige Pepe-Please-Musik.
Das geht bestimmt immer noch.
Das wird mir einen Pfennig kosten.
Aber es ist ein Kontext, also es ist alles in Ordnung.
Na, lasst uns anfangen.
Und das sollte so sein.
Alter, das geht aber lang.
Okay, wir skippen, wir skippen ein bisschen durch gleich.
Das ist Peter vom Microsoft Support.
Warte.
Der 12343 wird von außen aus dem Vereinigten Staaten angerufen.
Ah, geht nicht.
Er wird als internationaler Direkt-Dialog-Rate ausgeliefert.
Okay.
Ja, auf, mach hin.
Also, da geht mittlerweile...
Ich meine, schon deutlich bessere synthetische Sprache als das.
Was?
Was ist das?
Das war, das, das, das hat sich eher nach Baguette angehört.
Okay.
To consent your recording or monitoring of this call, press 1.
Or to continue without recording, oh, thank you, this call may be recorded or monitored.
Alter, geht das...
Das geht wahrscheinlich 20 Minuten jetzt so weiter.
Please enter the following number on your phone.
8.
2.
Warum?
Sorry, that doesn't match.
Let's try again.
Hä?
8, 2, that doesn't match.
...on your phone's touch-tone path.
8.
2, that still doesn't match.
Enter the following number on your phone's touch-tone path.
Ist das so ein AtCaptcha über das Telefon?
8.
2.
Unfortunately, we are unable to verify you.
...we can't help back in time yet.
Scammed.
Abi, da ist bestimmt irgendeine Cortana AI dahinter.
Wasn't that it?
Yeah.
I got kind of stuck in the verification procedure.
That's not well thought through, but rather only.
At first...
I though that I was...
russian not understanding english words correctly which sometimes is a problem
especially when listening to a phone speaker was das problem
wo ist das problem
was are you talking about that's a scam but eventually i realized that i was typing
the number they were telling me too quickly oh oh zu schnell nothing ever goes to plan
i wasted a few usa minutes worth of balance but no big deal let's continue
also diese schlechte diese schlechte speech text to speech triggert mich richtig
ach das war jetzt okay ach das war jetzt okay vorher nicht alles klar
windows
was
yes
Bei Gott, ist das schlecht.
Yes.
No.
Das ist ja heftig.
Okay, schafft er es jetzt noch irgendwo?
Ah, nee, hier geht's weiter.
Alter, okay, wie lang geht das?
Wie lang geht das jetzt noch?
Schafft er es denn am Ende eigentlich noch?
Ah.
Scheint zu funktionieren.
Warum fangen die mit C zu G an und machen dann A und B?
Information.
Everything was in shambles at that point, but I figured it was pretty dumb.
Since the boat on the other side was breaking.
Like, listen to it.
Okay, I'll wait a little.
Das Ding kackt voll ab.
Das kackt voll ab.
Okay, und, funktioniert's?
Hey, es ist aktiviert.
Meine Güte, warst du nackt.
Es hat ja schon wehgetan, nur beim Zugucken.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Äh, epische Mittelalterschlachten, Battlefield 3 Top Plays hätten wir auch noch zu bieten.
Äh, Github Copilot.
Da bin...
Da gibt es jetzt ja schon, ich glaube, diese, diesen, äh, Github, Github Copilot Geschichte
hat Microsoft nur rausgebracht, dass ganz viele Leute Github Memes produzieren.
Ich, ich, wirklich, ich habe letzte Woche kaum, kaum was mehr, äh, Postings gesehen als zu Github Copilot.
Auf Twitter.
Jeder hat sich drüber lustig gemacht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du eine Funktion nennst, do I suck, kommt zurück, automatisch, AI completed, return, yes.
Und sowas, also.
Okay, AI Blockchain, jawohl.
In the not so distant future, you'll likely be writing far fewer lines of code than you are today.
Beleise.
Your intelligence is coming to a BS code near you.
Microsoft...
Übrigens, ich glaube tatsächlich, jetzt mal unabhängig, so lustig das ist, dass, also, wer das nicht kennt, ich werde mal ganz kurz sagen, was das ist.
Das ist eine, eine, äh, künstliche Intelligenz trainiert mit dem Source Code, wahrscheinlich der auf Github ist, der Code-Vorschläge für dich macht.
Also man schreibt, was man haben möchte und das ist, die AI versucht dann das zu programmieren, was man quasi ihr gesagt hat.
Klappt mehr oder weniger gut.
Aber ich glaube, vom Ansatz her ist das wirklich die Zukunft.
Jetzt nicht für, nicht, nicht, nicht wirklich für, äh, Smartphone-App-Entwicklung oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ich glaube, dass, wenn wir das schaffen, oder ich muss, ich muss das, ich muss, ich muss das anders erzählen.
Also, es gibt ja schon jede Menge trainierte AIs, die relativ gut sind.
Die allerdings oftmals, wenn sie daneben liegen, total daneben liegen.
Zum Beispiel, es gab mal, ich glaube von Google oder Microsoft, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, gab es mal so ein Bild, so ein Bildbeschreibungs-Tool.
So eine Bildbeschreibungs-AI oder was es gab, gibt es.
So eine Bildbeschreibungs-AI.
Da lädst du, da, da, da lädst du zum Beispiel was hoch.
Keine Ahnung, hast deine Oma auf der Terrasse fotografiert im, im Schaukelstuhl.
Und du lädst das da hoch und dann sagt dir die AI, auf dem Bild ist zu sehen, äh, äh, elderly woman on, äh, was weiß ich, äh, on a chair.
Kommt dann zurück, okay.
Also, die Dinger sind dann relativ gut im Erkennen.
Aber, wenn die verkehrt liegen, dann liegen sie meistens meisterlich.
Meilenweit verkehrt.
Also sprich, du, wenn du deine Katze auf dem Sofa fotografierst und die AI sich vertut, dann kommt dann nicht etwa raus, äh, Katze auf dem Stuhl anstatt Katze auf dem Sofa.
Dann kommt dann raus, Vulkanausbruch in Island.
Oder sowas.
Also, wenn das falsch liegt, dann liegt das oftmals meilenweit falsch.
Ja, oder, oder, keine Ahnung, du hast, du fotografierst irgendwie, äh, du springst in den, in den, in den Swimmingpool in deinem Garten.
Und, äh.
Du lädst das da hoch und die AI macht's falsch, äh, erkennt's falsch.
Und da kommt dann, keine Ahnung, Pottwale bei der Paarung erkannt oder sowas.
Also, wenn das falsch liegt, liegt, liegt das oftmals krass, also total daneben, ja.
Und, gerade in diesem Bereich, so das, das, der, der möglichen Selbstoptimierung, da sehe ich schon viel Zukunft drin.
Fühl mich beleidigt.
Ja, ihr habt recht, ihr habt recht.
War vielleicht, war vielleicht gar nicht so weit weg von der Realität, ja.
Na gut.
Ähm.
Aber, äh, gerade, gerade in diesem Bereich sehe ich da schon, sehe ich da schon einiges, einiges in, an, an Potential, ja.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
GitHub.
Ja, das ist auch mega geil.
Das hat Microsoft gekauft.
Genau.
Richtig.
Genau, guck, du schreibst einen Kommentar.
Das, das soll die AI programmieren und dann macht die AI das.
Nur, dass das halt noch ein bisschen, naja.
Ja.
AI gegen Captcha, das gibt's schon.
Wer hat da eigentlich den Copyright für den Code, das ist eine echt gute Frage.
Ja.
Das ist der, das ist das nächste Level von, von Stack Overflow Driven Programming.
Du gehst jetzt nicht einfach nur auf Stack Overflow und copy-pastest.
Du hast direkt die AI im Editor, die irgendwas für dich zusammenwurstelt.
Das wird geil.
eine ganz neue Ebene von Sicherheitslücken geben.
Nämlich AI-generierte Sicherheitslücken.
Klar, Internet-Only.
Horst-Internet-Verbindung.
Leute, Java oder Java?
Was sagt ihr?
Ich persönlich mag Java.
JavaScript.
Ich sage auch JavaScript und nicht Java-script.
Java.
Ah, ich weiß es nicht.
Wie oft kopierst du noch aus Stack Overflow?
Stündlich.
Wenn wir über den automatisch generierten Code klicken, können wir auf Next klicken, um verschiedene Vorschläge durchzuführen.
Ich sehe eigentlich keine, die ich hier mag, also klicke ich auf die Open Co-Pilot-Option.
Das synthetisiert 10 verschiedene mögliche Lösungen und es passiert sehr schnell, wie innerhalb von einem oder zwei Sekunden.
Dann muss ich ja, dann muss ich jetzt erst noch durchlesen, was die AI programmiert hat.
Bis ich verstanden habe, was die AI programmiert hat, hätte ich es wahrscheinlich auch selbst programmiert.
Wenn ich mich näher an die Lösungen ansehe, sieht es aus, als ob sie alle ziemlich gleich sind.
Auch wenn ich weiß, dass es mehrere verschiedene Ansätze gibt, um sie zu implementieren.
Ein Intersection of Arrays.
The top answer on Stack Overflow actually has a cleaner implementation
and I would have expected this to at least be an option in the results.
But let's move on and see if we can build a little counter app that has multiple moving parts.
First I'm going to define some state, which is just a variable equal to zero.
You'll notice that it's trying to make predictions as I'm writing out this variable.
That is one thing that's kind of annoying.
Haben die jetzt in Visual, haben wir nicht letztens das, das, das aktuelle Visual Studio Preview ausprobiert
und die haben da auch so komisches Zeug drin versucht?
Mit Autocomplete AI und das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert.
It's almost a little too aggressive when making predictions.
It would be nice if the AI could predict when I actually want predictions.
Also it predicts things for React and Vue, even though I'm not in a React or Vue project.
In any case, the next thing I want to do here is grab a button from the DOM.
I'll give the AI a hint by writing a comment and you'll notice that it actually autocompletes the comment for me.
It knows exactly what I want to do because it's such a common thing to do.
Now that we have a button, let's set up an event listener on the click event.
To increment the state each time that it's clicked.
Now I start writing another comment.
I don't even type anything and it fills out that entire comment for me.
Es gibt doch gar kein Element ID zur Zeit, was Button heißt.
Na gut, das kann er dir ja einig wissen.
It's crazy because it's using the context of our previous line of code to figure out what to write next.
Ich meine, das ist echt schon ziemlich big brain.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, man kann sich da jetzt lustig machen, so viel man drüber will.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass es ja noch ganz am Anfang ist.
Und wie, ich sag mal in Anführungsstrichen, gut oder clever das jetzt schon funktioniert.
Auch wenn du jetzt noch damit nicht einfach fertig hinschreiben lassen kannst, es geht und es funktioniert.
Das ist ja immer noch, wir sind ja da immer noch ziemlich am Anfang.
Überlegt euch mal, wie das in 10 Jahren ausschaut.
Und spätestens wenn das Zeug wirklich anfangen kann, an sich selber rum zu feilen und zu verbessern, dann geht's ab.
Und ihr werdet bemerken, dass es einen Eventlisten auf den Button setzt.
Das heißt, es gibt einen Variablen, den wir definiert haben.
Dann geht es weiter, um den State zu updaten, indem wir ihn mit 1 erhöhen.
Es gibt auch ein Modulus 3 hier.
Ich weiß nicht genau, worum das geht.
Das wird es einfach zu 3 in einem Loop zählen.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wo es die Idee bekommen würde, das zu machen.
Und zum Schluss weiß es, dass wir das State in der UI zeigen wollen.
Also nimmt es unser Button und setzt das innere HTML zu dem aktuellen State.
Das ist ziemlich wild, aber jetzt werde ich in das HTML gehen und den Button an den DOM hinzufügen.
Es scheint nicht zu wissen, dass mein JavaScript einen bestimmten Button sucht.
Aber wenn ich einen Button kommentiere, wird es mit dem erwarteten Eingang autokompliziert.
Und zum Schluss gehen wir zu unserem CSS und geben es etwas Stil.
Wenn ich einen Kommentar für einen roten Button mit einem blauen Hintergrund gebe,
wird das Code von Linie nach Linie implementiert werden.
Aber es ist generell viel effizienter, einfach direkt zum Copilot zu gehen und die möglichen Optionen zu sehen.
Schafft man sich damit nicht selbst irgendwann als Programmierer ab?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich glaube, es geht da eher um so Optimierungen wie zum Beispiel,
dass der Bilderkennungsalgorithmus eben immer besser Bilder erkennt und sich da quasi selbst verbessert.
Nicht um das eigentliche Programm und den kreativen Prozess dahinter.
Einfach, dass die Dinger viel, viel effizienter sind,
Dinger durchzuprobieren und die notwendigen Informationen da rauszuholen.
Ich kann es auch schlecht einschätzen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir mit Terminator-Sachen da rechnen müssen.
Aber im Bereich, sagen wir mal so etwas wie Text-to-Speech,
oder Bildererkennung oder es gibt ja mittlerweile schon Services,
die fassen die Texte zusammen und so was.
Ich glaube, in dem Bereich könnte das richtig, richtig gute Verbesserungen bringen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so weit kommen wird, dass man eine AI hat zur Bildererkennung,
die auf einmal dann selbst sich umprogrammiert zu einer AI zur Steuerung des Flugverkehrs oder so was.
Das ist dann vielleicht ein bisschen sehr...
vielleicht ein bisschen sehr Science-Fiction-Style-mäßig weit hergeholt.
Ja, aber wir werden es erleben.
Und einen Vorteil hat es, AIs müssen keine Daily-Scrums machen.
Jedes Mal, wenn es geklickt wird, wird es den Status von einem Modulus von drei erhöhen.
All things considered, glaube ich, hat Copilot einen ziemlich guten Job gemacht.
Es fühlt sich ein bisschen an den Ecken rum,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall die beste AI-Coding-Erfahrung, die ich jemals hatte.
Aber wie funktioniert das eigentlich?
Nun, um eine nützliche AI zu bauen, benötigt man eine Menge Daten.
Glücklicherweise, in den letzten zwölf Jahren,
haben Entwickler ihre Zeit und Code dankbar übernommen,
um anderen Entwicklern auf der Internetseite zu helfen,
während sie ihre Copyright zu diesem Inhalt übernehmen,
primär auf der Webseite Stack Overflow,
die dieses Monat für 1,8 Billionen Dollar erhoben wurde.
Oh, ja, das habe ich mitgekriegt.
... für ihre Founder, um auszutauschen.
Nur Wochen bevor eine gesetzlich verändernde Gefahr die Industrie schlägt.
Es nimmt auch Code aus öffentlichen Open-Source-GitHub-Repos.
Nun, weil es einzigartige Code generiert hat,
denke ich nicht, dass es sich um irgendwelche Anforderungen
für Open-Source-Lizenzierung kümmern muss.
Nein, nein, nein.
Wer hat Stack Overflow gekauft?
Das war nicht Microsoft.
Das war irgendetwas, von dem ich vorher noch nichts gehört hatte.
... um ihre AI zu bauen.
Das Deep-Learning-Modell hinter den Daten
ist GPT-3.
Das ist richtig, Big Brain.
Ja.
... which is easily one of the most impressive AI products ever developed.
Das hat Microsoft gekauft.
People describe it as amazing, humbling and terrifying.
GPT-3 hat Microsoft alles gekauft.
... based on some initial context.
Like, it can take a complex article
and summarize it for a second later.
... or it can take an idea that you have for an ad
and generate the actual ad copy.
Under the hood, it's just a massive neural network
that's been trained on over 175 billion parameters.
Die heißen nicht wirklich SUS, die das gekauft haben, oder?
Ach, die Prosos.
... there are many popular pre-trained neural networks out there,
and none of them have anywhere close to one billion parameters,
let alone a hundred and seventy-five billion.
It's developed by a company called OpenAI,
that was founded by people like Elon Musk, Sam Altman
... und die üblichen Verdächtigen mal wieder.
Aber Microsoft hat das gekauft.
... but I think they realized they could make a shitload of money
and converted to a for-profit company in 2019.
Now, Microsoft doesn't control OpenAI,
but they did make a one-billion-dollar investment in 2019.
Oder so.
In September 2020, they announced they had licensed
the exclusive use of GPT-3.
Okay, sie haben es nicht gekauft,
sie haben die Exklusivrechte, es zu benutzen.
Kommt ja, kommt ja für uns ausgleiche aus.
... API, but Microsoft is the only company
that can truly take full advantage of the GPT-3 algorithm.
That means Microsoft will be able to build...
Die Welle passt, jawohl!
... unless, of course, you can build an algorithm...
Warum ZDF?
... that's better than GPT-3?
Lief das wirklich im ZDF?
... don't let the name fool you. OpenAI is not open.
A better name for it might be something like Windows AI.
Das ist ja aktuell so ein Trend,
dass man Sachen open nennt, die nicht open sind.
... great news for developers, right?
Ach, das ist Tencent. Ja, das darf ja nicht fehlen.
You can get your GitHub repos directly in VS Code,
GitHub Actions make continuous integration super easy,
and Copilot will just be one more awesome feature
to add to the list.
But it makes me wonder,
why does Microsoft love us developers so much?
Historically, Microsoft has not had a great relationship
with developers.
Die Welle passt, die Welle passt, die Welle passt.
Modern Microsoft has been doing a lot of embracing
and extending, but who knows if they have any plans
for the extinguish step.
Now, I'm just joking around here,
but let's imagine that the goal was to replace developers with AI.
Programmers are expensive, in short supply,
and one of the biggest expenses for any tech company.
To replace them, you need a four-step plan.
Step one is to get them to share a bunch of public information
about their code.
In step two, we use that code to create a product
that makes developers happier and more productive.
The initial version won't be perfect,
but as more and more developers use it,
we'll collect more and more data
and reinforce the existing algorithm.
In theory, the algorithm will get so good
that we'll no longer need programmers who write code,
maybe just technicians who can help guide the algorithm
to the best place.
That's the dream of the BWL people.
You only need BWL people, no programmers anymore.
But when we get to this point,
they forgot one thing.
Long before you don't need programmers,
you don't need BWL people anymore.
... and pay a bunch of artificial
Azure coders by the second.
Copilot is free for now and only available
through a technical preview.
Also, wenn's mal so weit gekommen ist,
dass du quasi Programmierer und Logi und Sachen,
so kreative Sachen durch AI ersetzen kannst,
dann kannst du BWL und sonstige Dinger
schon viel, viel früher ersetzen.
... and to develop it into a commercial product in the future.
AWS already has CodeGuru for ML-powered code recommendations.
So the big players here are already introducing paid services
that will replace the jobs...
Aha, Amazon ist auch am Start. Ja, was sonst?
... by human coders.
We're currently on step three of the plan,
but again, I'm just joking around here.
This is just a meme channel.
I love Bill Gates and Microsoft.
And if you think they're motivated by anything
beyond their genuine love for developers,
then you must be the kind of person...
Also, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
So lächerlich diese Pressekonferenzen damals gewesen sind,
das war mir lieber als dieses emotionale Rumgequatsche
bei Windows 11.
Also, das fand ich ja wirklich grausam.
Der Typ hat ja fast geweint bei Windows 11 auf der Bühne.
Als er das angekündigt hat, weil das so emotional ist.
... then you must be the kind of person who thinks 2 plus 2 equals 4.
All I ask is that you hit like and subscribe to my channel...
Ist das nicht so?
... so I can be updated on the latest tools hitting our industry.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Also bei der Windows 11 Pressekonferenz,
die haben ja wirklich fast geweint beim Windows vorstellen.
So, wir gucken jetzt Battlefield 3.
Ich muss jetzt noch eine Runde Battlefield 3 gucken,
bevor ich Mittagessen gehe.
Ich hab mega Hunger.
Aber eine Runde Battlefield 3 muss noch sein.
Und ihr wisst, ich mach wie immer nicht lauter,
weil er immer das gleiche erzählt.
Weggeschneibt.
Wait a minute, was ist denn das?
Das ist Endgame DLC, das ist DLC-Map.
Da lassen sich wegschneibern.
Alter!
Schreckt!
Richtig hardcore schreckt hier.
That intro clip was absolutely awesome.
Finding the motherload of enemy players...
Alles weggenau scoped.
Next up we have Cubic with a huge sniping spree
on Damavan Peak using an S3 and S2.
Alter, die lassen sich bashen.
Das ist ein cooler Clip.
Ich mag generell, gibt's leider viel zu wenig in Battlefield 3,
so offensive sniping Gedöns.
Das find ich geil.
Das ist nice.
Guck ich mir gerne an.
Zack!
In your face.
Komm, und jetzt noch einmal kreiseln.
Einmal kreiseln.
Nee.
Metro backrage time.
Here we have TC Bounty with one of his...
Er wieder, er wieder.
...flanks on Operation Metro.
You love to see it getting behind the enemy players
and destroying every single one of them.
Er wieder.
Das ist wieder so eine ganz, ganz faire Spawn-Metro-Runde.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Alle Flanken, alles hier drüben.
It looks like Duffy4 only used force.
I might be mistaken, but...
Jetzt wird wieder erstmal alles...
Oh!
Oh, in your face!
Bam!
Ba-bam!
Alter!
Und jetzt noch...
Oh, nice!
Jetzt hat er noch einen Shotgun aufgehoben.
Poggers!
Oh, die kriegen auf den Sack.
Alter, haben die auf den Sack gekriegt.
Nice, nice, nice.
Kranker Scheiß.
Well killed.
Let's go.
Die hat er aber echt auseinandergenommen jetzt.
Two Clips from everyone's favorite long range weapon.
Oh, der Typ wieder.
Geh weg.
Der sitzt die ganze Runde rum und sniperet sich einen ab und macht drei Kills die Runde.
Okay, wenigstens sehe ich den Gegner diesmal.
Der sitzt am Arsch der Welt und macht drei Kills die Runde, ja.
Der hat das schon geübt, das sieht man.
Aber das bringt trotzdem null, null dem Rundenwin.
Moving on to a good old Operation Metro Run and Gun Clear.
It's Archer.
Metro, was sonst?
This is a really nice showcase for the P90 as everything in his way...
Hä?
Das war schöner Battlefield 3 netcode hier wieder.
Guckt es euch an.
Moving on to a good old Operation Metro Run and Gun Clear.
It's Archer.
This is a really nice showcase for the P90...
What the fuck?
Warum ist der nicht gestorben?
Ich meine, da hat er wie viel Schuss reingehauen?
20?
It's Archer.
Ja.
This is a really nice showcase for the P90...
15?
...as everything in his way...
Ah ja, okay.
Es ist...
Battlefield 3, ja.
Oh, der hat ganz schön lag, der Dude auch.
Das...
Der...
Von dem haben wir schon öfters Clip gehabt.
Das ist der mit dem Activate Windows-Typ, ja.
Was ist denn das?
Windows 7?
Ist das das Windows 7 Activate?
Windows 10?
Ah, Windows 10 hat doch gar keinen...
Activate Overlay.
Ach, ihr seht nix.
Ja, das ist nicht schlimm.
Ja, das ist...
Ja, Hüft...
Hüftspray P90.
Das ist...
Deswegen mag ich das Ding.
Du kannst einfach across the map hipfiren und was killen.
Alter, jetzt werden sie wieder weggesprayt.
Nachladen.
Und rausgehen, wegsprayen.
Bam.
Jawoll.
Warum will er die jetzt unbedingt marken?
Kann er die nicht einfach P90en?
Two Clips from Dexta Next.
This one is on Grand Bazaar.
Bringing back some of those great memories of those Hexen.
So.
da eine gute Pose hast, da kannst du auch einfach mal 5 Minuten stehen und gerade ausschießen
und du killst 30 Leute. Ah, jetzt hat er den Fehler gemacht, den hätte ich auch gemacht,
nämlich reingepusht. Ist ja viel besser gewesen, einfach stehen zu bleiben. Oh, underrated
Map. Richtig underrated Map. Doch, ist es. Ist es. Ich finde, das ist eines der besten
Battlefield 3 Maps. Was erzählt der denn für ein Scheiß? Anzeige ist raus. Die haben
alle so einen krassen Lag. Die hören auf zu schießen und eine halbe Minute später
stirbt der Gegner. Jawoll. Wegsprayen, so muss das sein. Oh, oh. Okay, der Typ, der
war braindead. Die sind alle braindead. Aber ist okay, nur so kannst du solche Clips hinkriegen.
Aber richtig nicer Clip.
Ist ja besonders.
Ah, Sellout. Sellout. Aber wir lassen ihn, wenn wir sein Content schon gucken, lassen
wir ihn eine Runde Sellout machen. Das war der Test für die Battlefield 2042 Bots. Das
ist möglich, ja. Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wenn die Bots so gut wären in 2042, dann, die sind bestimmt Blockchain AI trainiert.
So, ihr wisst ja, ohne AI in Blockchain geht heute gar nichts mehr.
Oh, Resident Sleeper.
Ah, Jet Snipes.
Cool, wenn man es macht, aber so an den Spalten zuzugucken ist es nicht. Sag mal, wie fliegen
die Typen eigentlich? Ist das gestellt? Ach, ne, der will den Panzer bashen unten. Okay,
okay. Ja, ne, ne, passt. Lass ich mir gefallen.
Andy the Lion is next with a Rush Clip on Grand Bazaar. He's using the common loadout
of the M16A3 and Rex, going to work on this enemy team. You have to realize as well, he's
pretty much doing this on his own, not with a squad or a team behind him. So, if you're
interested, check it out.
with a squad or a team behind him. So, it's a lone wolf clip. You really need these sort
of players in Rush if you want to win.
Ja, ja, du musst, musst, musst wiederbeleben. Ohne, ohne wiederbeleben hast du gelitten.
Du kannst nicht 1 gegen 20 spielen. Du bist nicht konstant. Erst mal M16 in your face,
beste.
Das ist wenigstens mal ein cooler, realistischer Clip. Bashen und wiederbeleben. Das, was man
als guter Medic macht oder als Assault.
Bashen und wiederbeleben. So musst du es machen. Was ist das überhaupt für eine
pepega Auflösung? 800x600 oder was? 900x600. Oh, jetzt wurde er sinnlos gehittet. Von irgend
so einem Hüftspray Support Typ. Er wurde weggesprüht und gebetet.
Ich spiele auf dem Laptop. Ja, das kann tatsächlich sein. Da ist er wieder.
Okay.
Und das ist ein typischer Metro Rampage, der durch das Gegenteil des Teams durchkommt.
Das ist keine Metro.
Es regnet.
Also ein bisschen mehr Mühe geben beim kommentieren, könnte er sich ja.
Oh, jawoll, jawoll, jawoll. Bashen, Alter, Bashen, jawoll.
Alter, dass der das überlebt. Guck, er denkt sich schon, ich bin jetzt eigentlich dead,
aber die Leute kriegen es nicht gebacken.
Und jetzt werden sie wiederbelebt. Jetzt kann er sie wieder wegsprechen.
Sinti, sag mal.
Willst du es nicht checken, dass er hinter einem Stein liegt und dann auch noch an ihm
vorbeirennt?
Alter, der hat immer nice Clips.
Jetzt?
Nee.
Zum Schluss dieses Videos haben wir etwas etwas anderes und eine Chance für mich,
meine Gedanken über das nächste Battlefield-Spiel zu geben.
Dieser Clip von Dexter ist eine Menge von Kills.
Was für ein Ding?
Alles klar.
Ein langer Clip insgesamt.
Leider kriegt er auch einen Vote-Kick.
Das ist ein sehr guter Clip.
Kommt vor.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, dass ein Server ordentlich administriert und moderiert ist,
dass diese Quote von False Cheating Kicks möglichst gering ist und man auch die Cheater
erwischt, die jetzt nicht gerade super krasse Stats haben.
Manche halten sich ja da zurück.
Was bräuchte mal deine Hilfe?
Das gucken wir uns mal kurz rein.
Also was?
Moment.
Was bräuchte mal deine Hilfe bei folgenden Problemen?
Wenn ich meinen PC runterfahre und 8 Stunden auf Arbeit gehe, ist er, wenn ich nach Hause
komme, im Lockscreen-Modus habe ich jetzt App.
Was?
Ready im Bios?
Du fährst den wahrscheinlich nicht runter.
Der geht wahrscheinlich einfach nur Suspend to RAM oder Suspend to Disk.
Das ist einfach.
Okay.
Also Firmware oder Suspend to Disk.
Und irgendein Event weckt ihn wieder auf, zum Beispiel Mausbewegung oder so oder welch
Rola.
Ja.
Vielleicht, vielleicht putzt jemand deinen Schreibtisch und drückt aus Versehen einen
Knopf oder bewegt die Maus.
Der Rechner geht wieder an.
Du kannst das ausschalten.
Du kannst im Energie kannst du irgendwo im Energie.
Energie an Power.
Ich habe sie auf Englisch Power.
Du kannst irgendwo edit Power Settings Power Plan.
Kannst du irgendwie einstellen.
Was der machen soll beim runterfahren
Und da kannst du diesen Hybrid Standby
Gedöns ausschalten
Dann fährt er auch richtig runter
Und geht nicht einfach so an
Der Chat ist auch wieder High IQ
Das kann man alles ausprobieren
So bei der Gelegenheit übrigens
Guck an ob man es in die Subs
Er stellt es ab
Dankeschön
Vor 16 Monaten
Falls ihr es schon vorgelesen habt
Danke für den Massive High IQ Sub
Gebes Twitch hat abonniert
Dankeschön
Deck
Weiter
NKLux
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ja
Ach die machen
AI Blockchain Anti-Cheat
Kein Problem
Ja
Komm zum Punkt
needs to do something radically different for the next battlefield game habe ich auch schon gesagt
sie haben easy anti cheats which seems to work quite well for the most part maybe that's something
that they will move over to with wie sieht es denn bei apex wie sieht es denn bei apex mit cheatern
aus dass da schlimm oder nicht so schlimm wenn cheater gibt es überall aber somebody who only
makes videos i don't have a huge issue with cheaters they are there and i really wish that
they weren't so ich habe gesagt viele cheater might just join another server and that's really the
extent of it for me it ruins the fun but i can kind of work around it with streamers though they
are harassed by cheaters followed round by cheaters and the sort of people that will cheat in a video
game you can pretty much guarantee they will do other things as well stream snipe follow people
round ruin the experience even crash servers on background
battlefield 4 if they can thankfully that's not something that can really be done in
battlefield games since this gives dice a responsibility in my opinion to do something
about this whether it's a better anti-cheat or offering a streamer mode for those streamers big
or small that want to promote this game enjoy this game and share their experience to the world
having an anti-cheat is essential to that i did mention before about the custom servers that will
allow you to ban and kick people i don't like that
personally in a battlefield game if somebody's doing really well you shouldn't just be able to
boot them off the server yeah irgendwo irgendwo muss ja mal ein strich machen wenn sie es mit
anti-cheat auch von offizieller seite nicht hinbekommen was bleibt mir anderes übrig als
auf custom server so was wie ein vote kick system zu machen das beste verfahren ist natürlich man
hat einen server wo permanent mods und admins drauf sind in observer slots und sich die spieler
angucken und dann realistisch entscheiden aber mal ernsthaft wer macht das hobby mäßig
macht doch niemand wie soll das funktionieren setzt sich doch keiner ganzen tag hin das müsste
dann höchstens ein paid server sein auf dem du bezahlst zu spielen aber das wäre dann schon
eigentlich auch irgendwie naja
AI-Programmieren genau AI-Blockchain alles gut
In Overwatch kriegen sie es zum Beispiel ganz gut hin
auch wenn es cheater gibt
Battlefield 3 Royale haben wir uns schon angeguckt
Ja haben wir uns schon angeguckt
einfach das spiel in kobold programmieren da wird es mit dem cheaten auch schwer warum ich
weiß dass sich als gewalt aber was hat es was hat die programmieren sprache des programmiertes für
den einfluss drauf ob man schicken kann oder nicht wie viel spieler auf der wahl statt ja
das sagt ja dazu nichts mehr die wissen schon warum kann es davon ausgehen wenn es so viele
wäre dass blizzard damit gut werbung machen könnte würden sie spieler zahlen veröffentlichen alle die
aufhören spieler zahlen zu veröffentlichen sind nicht zufrieden mit den spieler zahlen ist einfach
so welchen grund hätte man sonst spieler zahlen nicht mehr zu veröffentlichen außer wenn man
nicht damit zufrieden ist oder denkt man kann damit nicht mehr gut werbung machen gibt es
eigentlich kein grund solange spieler zahlen gut sind und man damit werbung machen kann veröffentlicht
man spieler zahlen wenn man dann auf einmal wieder aufhört
spieler zahlen zu veröffentlichen sagt das eigentlich nur aus die spieler zahlen sind
haben sie schlecht entwickelt der friseur der friseur ist übrigens on mechanics hier guck
mal der friseur ey frisi den hosten wir jetzt übrigens auch gleich der frisi wo ist er dann
der ist on hab ich vorhin gesehen der grinded mit der engfälscher asia mmos ich wollte übrigens mit
ich wollte übrigens mitspielen die aktuelle season fällt mir gerade ein aber ich hab's
die letzten tage nicht dazu durchringen können mich wieder ein video mal einzuloggen
leute ich geh jetzt eh auf ich geh jetzt essen ich hab hunger wir raiden jetzt wir raiden jetzt
den den fraser könnt ihr könnt ihr einfach mal eine runde voll spam und wenn euch mmos nicht
interessieren dann könnt ihr wieder rausgehen ob die meisten von euch die sind jetzt nicht
so großartige mmo bdo fans kann ich ein sind bei einem klick keine ahnung der thorsten meldet sich
zurück also leute wir sehen uns bis zum nächsten stream
bis denn